programming throwdown episode 177 vector databases take it away patrick welcome everyone to another episode we have a great topic today. I'm excited to learn. It's legitimately something that I hear all about, but I don't know too much about. So we're going to have Teacher Jason joining us here in a minute. That's right. We had Teacher Patrick for compilers and interpreters. And then we have now Teacher Jason for vector DBs.
Programming Throwdown 第 177 期，向量数据库。Patrick，开始吧。欢迎大家收听新的一期节目，我们今天有一个很棒的话题。我很兴奋能学习一下。这确实是我经常听到，但了解不深的东西。所以我们一会儿会请 Jason 老师加入我们。没错。我们之前有编译器和解释器方面的 Patrick 老师，现在我们有向量数据库方面的 Jason 老师。
I feel like we should have called ourselves professors. We missed opportunity there. Oh, that's right. What's, is there anything higher? Uh, distinguished, uh, a Mertis professor,
我觉得我们应该自称教授。我们错失了一个机会。哦，对了。还有比这更高的头衔吗？呃，杰出教授，名誉教授，
a Mertis, a Merti. I, I, okay. What's the highest level professor? Uh, you know,
名誉教授，名誉。我，我，好吧。最高级别的教授是什么？呃，你知道，
can you, can you, can you, can you, can you, can you, can you, can you,
你能，你能，你能，你能，你能，你能，你能，你能，
can you, can you, can you, can you, soul emperor of the knowledge universe. Oh, but what if it thinks it's the smartest it's gonna tell you a lie because like it doesn't want you to be superior okay anyway no sorry oh you know i have this plan now when um you know when i get these calls from people telling me that like my my taxes are overdue or i should buy car insurance or whatever what i've started doing is asking it questions about particle physics.
你能，你能，你能，你能，知识宇宙的灵魂皇帝。哦，但如果它认为自己是最聪明的，它会告诉你谎话，因为它不想让你比它优越。好吧，不管怎样，不，抱歉。哦，你知道，我现在有个计划，当，嗯，你知道，当我接到那些电话，告诉我我的税款逾期了，或者我应该买汽车保险之类的，我开始做的是问它关于粒子物理学的问题。
And when it gives me really good answers, I'm like, aha, this is chat GPT. This is not even a real person. A particle physicist could work in a call center. Okay. Yeah.
当它给我非常好的答案时，我就想，啊哈，这是 ChatGPT。这甚至不是一个真人。粒子物理学家可能会在呼叫中心工作。好吧。是的。
I mean, I had to go looking for a car and they legitimately like you know want your phone number whatever so i just have one of the like you know uh i guess like it's a voice over ip number but it doesn't actually like ring through whatever and the place one of the places i went has called me twice a day every day for going on two weeks now and i've picked up zero of the calls and i'm just like they really want to sell me a car but it turns me off i'm just like why are you pestering me this much like i feel like just text me i will so you know my dad worked for uh a few different car dealerships over the span of about 30 years
我的意思是，我不得不去找车，他们确实，你知道，想要你的电话号码之类的，所以我只是用了一个，你知道，呃，我想这就像是一个 VoIP 号码，但它实际上并没有接通之类的，我去过的地方之一已经连续两周每天给我打两次电话了，我一次都没接，我只是觉得他们真的很想卖给我车，但这让我很反感，我只是想，为什么你要这样纠缠我？我感觉就像，直接发短信给我吧，我会的。所以你知道，我父亲在过去大约 30 年里为几家不同的汽车经销商工作过，
and so i learned the trick to buying a car and i'll share it with everybody if you're a programming throwdown listener for free you don't have to be a patron although we really appreciate it um if you want to buy a car here's what you do you show up you test drive the car in person so they know you're a real person you're not another dealer trying to buy a car and then resell it you know you're there as an individual buy car you prove it to them right uh and then you leave and you don't come back until you have everything finalized so everything is over email or phone you negotiate the price you compare with other dealers and uh you should expect this to take about a month um but if you do that you will save anywhere from like 10 to 30 percent of the price wow i last time i bought my car i felt like it was pretty different than now and that like the
所以我学会了买车的诀窍，我会免费分享给所有人，如果你是 Programming Throwdown 的听众，你不需要成为赞助人，尽管我们非常感谢。嗯，如果你想买车，你应该这样做：你到场，亲自试驾这辆车，这样他们就知道你是一个真实的人，而不是另一个试图买车然后转卖的经销商，你知道，你作为个人去买车，你向他们证明了这一点，对吧？呃，然后你离开，直到一切都敲定之前不要回来，所以一切都在电子邮件或电话中进行，你协商价格，你与其他经销商比较，呃，你应该预计这需要大约一个月的时间，但如果你这样做，你将节省大约 10% 到 30% 的价格。哇，我上次买车时，感觉和现在很不一样，因为
inventories are much worse um but yeah in general i did something similar to what you were saying for the last time about a car it was super nice i just showed up like all the paperwork was done you know just basically it still took you know close to an hour which is ridiculous um but you know pretty much it was all ready to go so yeah that i i agree i'm going to attempt to do this one again i haven't gotten to the negotiating stage yet so but showing up i guess they're trying to you know do the cap show with me so they're trying to call me back and make sure the phone number is real yeah i haven't bought a car since uh 2020 and so i've i've missed this shortage but is the shortage still a thing or is it over i don't think it's a
库存情况要糟糕得多，嗯，但总的来说，我上次买车时做了和你说的类似的事情，这非常好，我只是到场，所有的文书工作都完成了，你知道，基本上还是花了将近一个小时，这很荒谬，但你知道，基本上一切都准备好了，所以是的，我同意，我打算再试一次，我还没到谈判阶段，所以，但到场，我想他们是在试图，你知道，对我进行验证码测试，所以他们试图回电给我，确保电话号码是真的。是的，我自 2020 年以来就没买过车，所以我错过了这次短缺，但短缺还在持续吗？还是已经结束了？我不认为它
thing in the same way but the inventories on like desirable stuff is still not great and um at least at the places i was like i think it varies dealer to dealer how much they've you know or brand to brand i guess how much they've recovered um so uh yeah i think it's it's still on the pricing is is tighter but i i don't know i will still die on the hill that i think we are stupid for having gotten ourselves and i guess this is us-centric people tell me in other countries it's not like this but i have no idea why you go in and the only place in life remaining is a car dealership where you have to like negotiate. I'm going to bring in my manager. I'm going to bring in the finance.
还是那样，但像热门车型的库存仍然不太好，嗯，至少在我去的地方，我想这因经销商而异，或者因品牌而异，我想他们恢复了多少，所以，呃，是的，我认为它仍然很紧张，定价也更紧，但我不知道，我仍然会坚持认为，我们让自己陷入这种境地是很愚蠢的，我想这是以美国为中心的，人们告诉我其他国家不是这样的，但我不知道为什么你要进去，生活中唯一剩下的地方就是汽车经销商，你必须像协商一样。我要叫我的经理来。我要叫财务部门来。
We're going to change everything on you. Like it's a total like scammy thing the whole way through. Oh, yeah. That's another thing. So the thing about finance, you ever play these mobile games where there's like 24 different currencies you know like i play uh fifa on mobile and there's like there's literally five five to ten different currencies at any given time and some of them get phased out and replaced with other currencies and all that um but there's one currency that like you could pay real money to get
我们要为你改变一切。就像整个过程完全是一个骗局。哦，是的。那是另一回事。关于财务，你玩过那种有 24 种不同货币的手机游戏吗？你知道，比如我玩手机版的 FIFA，随时都有五到十种不同的货币，其中一些会被淘汰并被其他货币取代，所有这些，嗯，但有一种货币，你可以花真钱去买，
and that's ultimately the only currency that really matters because that's one currency that like you could pay real money to get. And that's ultimately the only currency that really matters because that's the one that's tied to USD. Right. And so if you start going down the finance route early, you end up in this boat where they're like, oh, your monthly payments are the same. But like they really they added a year of payments, you know, but each month is the same. And there's just there's just like too many variables and it's like pretty easy to get trick um and so that's that's another thing that my dad told me was like always like negotiate the absolute dollar amount and then come in at the very end and do financing after like you're ready to pay the amount whatever so this has turned into a
而这最终是唯一真正重要的货币，因为那是唯一一种你可以花真钱买到的货币。而这最终是唯一真正重要的货币，因为那是与美元挂钩的货币。对。所以如果你过早地走上财务路线，你最终会陷入这种境地，他们会说，哦，你的月供是一样的。但他们实际上增加了一年的还款期，你知道，但每个月都是一样的。而且变量太多了，很容易被骗，所以这是我父亲告诉我的另一件事，总是协商绝对的美元金额，然后在最后进来，在准备好支付金额后进行融资，所以这已经变成了
little bit of advice from jason and a lot of whining from patrick uh but yeah buying a car i look forward to i will say from what i understand tesla does it a little different i look forward to you know some future for my children or whatever where like you literally just figure it out online maybe you show up to test drive once and then you just buy and it doesn't matter if you buy from the one on the west side of town or east side of town it's all the same like yeah every other thing we go to and do so yeah exactly can't come soon enough all right and i'm sorry for all the car dealership people that i probably you know very frustrating to or putting out of business. But you know, yeah, if you're a car dealer, message us, we'll take we'll take your hate and read it on the air for everyone to hear. Oh, no, no. All right, we're jumping into news.
一点 Jason 的建议和很多 Patrick 的抱怨，但是的，买车，我很期待，我会说据我所知，特斯拉的做法有点不同，我很期待，你知道，为我的孩子们或什么的未来，就像你真的只是在网上搞定它，也许你到场试驾一次，然后你就买了，无论你是从城西还是城东的店买的都一样，就像我们去做的每一件事一样，所以是的，完全正确，迫不及待了。好的，我很抱歉，对于所有我可能，你知道，非常令人沮丧或导致失业的汽车经销商人员。但是，你知道，是的，如果你是汽车经销商，给我们发消息，我们会接受你的仇恨，并在广播中读出来让大家听到。哦，不，不。好了，我们要进入新闻环节了。
All right. So my first article talking about programming things here, cognitive load is what matters. So this is actually a GitHub article, which is a kind of interesting way to do it. So the person can update it over time. And this is something that I picked, I will say a little selfishly because I say this all the time at work and there'll be a link in the show notes. But just talking about in development,
好的。所以我的第一篇文章谈论编程方面的事情，认知负荷才是最重要的。所以这实际上是一篇 GitHub 文章，这是一种很有趣的方式。所以作者可以随着时间的推移更新它。这是我选的，我会说有点自私，因为我在工作中一直这么说，节目笔记中会有链接。但只是谈论开发，
that one of the most, in software development, one of the most overlooked things is how much cognitive load you're putting on the engineers and this can come in a couple forms and they kind of call them out like sometimes that could be the business surrounding the code um i work at a place that does like lots of software engineering so it's it's a pretty like respected part of the business but a lot of businesses you may only have one, two, three, four software engineers building something. And so the bulk of the business isn't really the development or the software. And so there's all sorts of like, hey, you really need to work with
在软件开发中，最被忽视的事情之一是你给工程师施加了多少认知负荷，这可以以几种形式出现，他们将其指出来，有时这可能是围绕代码的业务，嗯，我在一个做很多软件工程的地方工作，所以这是业务中一个相当受人尊敬的部分，但很多企业你可能只有一、二、三、四名软件工程师在构建东西。所以大部分业务并不是开发或软件。所以有各种各样的，嘿，你真的需要和
the accounting team and this team and that team and who talks to whom and this is using this database and this person is using this other one. All of that has to be loaded into your head. The other thing I always bring up that people forget is you go to college and you learn all this stuff about compilers and programming and you show up on the job and they give you like an unconfigured Linux box. And maybe you've only ever used Windows or you've only ever used Mac OS. And now it's like, hey, here's this Linux box. Congratulations.
会计团队和这个团队和那个团队合作，谁和谁交谈，这个正在使用这个数据库，那个人正在使用另一个。所有这些都必须加载到你的脑子里。我总是提到的另一件事是人们忘记了，你上大学，你学习了所有关于编译器和编程的东西，然后你出现在工作中，他们给你一个未配置的 Linux 盒子。也许你只用过 Windows，或者你只用过 Mac OS。现在就像，嘿，这是这个 Linux 盒子。恭喜。
Like configure it, install your packages. Oh, you need to like, you you know move your pc to a different location and plug in all the cables but wait a minute like is that really like a requirement listed for the job that like you know bash or zsh or any of these shell scripting and so the amount of cognitive load that goes into um programming and and then you know, I think kind of the bulk of the article is when you're selecting paradigms, abstractions, where to divide stuff, how much to copy and paste,
配置它，安装你的包。哦，你需要，你知道，把你的电脑搬到不同的位置并插上所有的电缆，但等一下，这真的是工作中列出的要求吗，比如你知道 bash 或 zsh 或任何这些 shell 脚本，所以投入到编程中的认知负荷量，然后，你知道，我认为文章的大部分内容是当你选择范式、抽象、在哪里划分东西、复制和粘贴多少时，
there's a balance to be reached. If you make, you know, stuff too small and modular or too monolithic, both introduce a lot of cognitive overload. So there's the balance there but actively thinking about how do we build this in a way that makes it easy to reason about so things that are similar are kept together um and not abstractions for abstraction's sake is an important thing the one that always gets up like we program in c++ and it's like everybody
需要达到一种平衡。如果你把东西做得太小、太模块化或太单一，两者都会引入大量的认知过载。所以这里有平衡，但积极思考我们如何以一种易于推理的方式构建它，这样相似的东西被放在一起，而不是为了抽象而抽象，这是一件重要的事情。那个总是被提起的，比如我们用 C++ 编程，每个人都
aha look i wrote the ternary operator which is you write a you know conditional expression like an if statement you know a greater than b and then you do a question mark and then the first thing is what happens if it's true and then you do a colon and then you put the second thing okay just write an if else statement or an if then like like you are i have seen i've been programming for a long time i see yes i can parse it but i don't parse it as fast and i always have to double check like wait a minute it's the true is the first one false is the second one and secondly when we bring on a new person maybe you say hey we're all
啊哈，看，我写了三元运算符，也就是你写一个，你知道，条件表达式，像 if 语句，你知道 a 大于 b，然后你打一个问号，然后第一件事是如果为真会发生什么，然后你打一个冒号，然后你放第二件事。好吧，直接写一个 if else 语句或者 if then 就像你一样，我编程很长时间了，我看到，是的，我可以解析它，但我解析得没那么快，我总是不得不仔细检查，等一下，真值是第一个，假值是第二个，其次，当我们引入一个新人时，也许你说，嘿，我们都是
experienced people uh and this comes up in a later news article but when new people come on how like maybe they aren't used to that so using and this is matters for some languages more than other. But using like the subset of the language that is most comprehensible and most widely used gives you benefits and that it's very easy to bring new people on. It's very easy to teach. And we were working with a code base where they like put in a ton of macros. All of the, you know, variable names are single line, single character, variable names, all this stuff. And they may be efficient in programming,
有经验的人，这在后面的新闻文章中会提到，但当新人加入时，他们可能不习惯那样，所以使用，这对于某些语言比其他语言更重要。但使用最易懂、最广泛使用的语言子集会给你带来好处，而且非常容易引入新人。非常容易教。我们正在处理一个代码库，他们放入了大量的宏。所有的，你知道，变量名都是单行、单字符变量名，所有这些东西。它们在编程中可能是高效的，
but you cannot work with them, you can't work with that code base. And all this is about that, you know, thinking about cognitive load, and really programming in a way that reduces it. Yeah, I've seen so much, like, kind of bad behavior with macros and metaprogramming and C++. It just makes it so difficult. It's like, oh, you know, I'm using like the double hashtag thing to like concaten this this call to a preprocessor macro to create a class and i'm doing that call like 30 times and so none of these classes actually exist anywhere so like you know it messes up the ide and everything and and you know at some point it's like look if you were to copy paste this class 30 times well first of all there should be a better way of doing it but let's say you just couldn't figure it out just copy paste the class 30 times at least that way someone can see kind of the point and the pattern and all that if you if you hide it behind a
但你无法使用它们，你无法处理那个代码库。所有这些都是关于那个，你知道，思考认知负荷，并真正以一种减少它的方式编程。是的，我见过太多关于宏和元编程的糟糕行为，在 C++ 中。这太困难了。就像，哦，你知道，我正在使用双井号之类的东西来连接这个对预处理器宏的调用以创建一个类，我做了 30 次那个调用，所以这些类实际上在任何地方都不存在，所以，你知道，它搞乱了 IDE 和所有东西，而且，你知道，在某种程度上，就像，看，如果你要复制粘贴这个类 30 次，好吧，首先，应该有一种更好的方法来做，但假设你就是想不出来，直接复制粘贴这个类 30 次，至少那样别人可以看到重点和模式之类的，如果你把它隐藏在
reprocessor macro it just becomes like a tar pit that people get stuck in and i think there are other languages that the same thing happens or even you know the way of doing object modeling and i've seen stuff in java with you know getting into dependency injection and reflection at runtime and just like it makes it really hard to like hey i have a call site here what code is being executed like how many hoops do you have to jump through if you don't know off the top of your head to find the actual line of code invoked?
预处理器宏后面，它就变成了一个人们会被困住的焦油坑，我认为在其他语言中也会发生同样的事情，或者甚至，你知道，对象建模的方式，我在 Java 中见过一些东西，你知道，涉及到依赖注入和运行时的反射，这使得它真的很难，比如，嘿，我这里有一个调用点，什么代码正在执行？如果你不知道，你需要跳过多少个圈才能找到实际调用的代码行？
And how confident are you that you found the actual line that is being invoked? And if that is not a trivial amount of time, you should be really, really thoughtful about trying to reduce that
你有多确信你找到了实际被调用的那一行？如果这不是一个微不足道的时间量，你应该非常、非常认真地考虑尝试减少它
as much as you can. Yep. Yep. Yeah, totally. Yeah. Dependency injection is uh in java i remember um i forgot what the tool was called but there was this tool where like you would maybe it was part of the spring framework but you would pass in um uh like a config and it would create classes from this config and feed them into your main function. And, and so it's like, oh, like, this object is already filled in. What the heck,
尽可能多地减少。是的。是的。是的，完全正确。是的。依赖注入在 Java 中，我记得，嗯，我忘了那个工具叫什么了，但有这个工具，你会，也许它是 Spring 框架的一部分，但你会传入，嗯，一个配置，它会从这个配置中创建类并将它们输入到你的主函数中。所以就像，哦，这个对象已经被填充了。搞什么鬼，
like, how do I change it? Oh, I it's actually in an XML file. It's like, what, you know, it just became really hard to use. Moving on to diffusion models are real-time game engines um i i don't know i don't necessarily agree with the premise of this but the thing about this that blew my mind is the video so basically what people did is they took these like image generators and text image you know that whole like a vision transformer kind of technology and they basically used it to say if i have this image of a screenshot of a video game in this case they use doom because it's open source and people use it on everything so given this screenshot of a Doom game, or maybe even like a handful of screenshots
我该怎么改变它？哦，它实际上在一个 XML 文件里。就像，什么，你知道，它变得真的很难使用。继续讨论扩散模型是实时游戏引擎，我，我不知道，我不一定同意这个前提，但关于这个让我大吃一惊的是视频，所以基本上人们所做的是他们采用了这些图像生成器和文本图像，你知道，那种视觉转换器技术，他们基本上用它来说，如果我有这个电子游戏的截图，在这种情况下他们使用 Doom，因为它是开源的，人们在所有东西上都使用它，所以给定这个 Doom 游戏的截图，或者甚至像一把截图
of the last second of this Doom game, and given a command like shoot a gun or go forward or whatever, then generate the next screenshot of the game. And so they basically are trying to encode the entire doom game like the art assets the engine everything into a diffusion model um and so then they proceed to play this game and it just gets it just gets kind of weird like uh you know points of discontinuity are really difficult for these models like so for example um when you fire the weapon sometimes it doesn't fire um you get the fire animation but like you know that the world isn't affected um and other times it is um sometimes like you walk
在 Doom 游戏的最后一秒，给定一个命令，比如开枪或向前走之类的，然后生成游戏的下一张截图。所以他们基本上是在尝试将整个 Doom 游戏，比如艺术资产、引擎、所有东西编码到一个扩散模型中，然后他们继续玩这个游戏，它只是变得有点奇怪，比如，你知道，不连续点对这些模型来说真的很难，所以例如，当你开火时，有时它不开火，你得到了开火动画，但你知道世界没有受到影响，而其他时候它受到了影响，有时你走，
and a door is just kind of like flickering in and out of existence um the whole thing is wild uh uh you really uh we're not doing it justice here over audio uh but go to the show notes and watch the video um it's just pretty uh i've seen a lot of like weird things with doom like they passed it through daydream and you have this like really weird uh uh you know kind of like trippy kind of uh uh you know view of it um but this is really taking it to the next level like you're defying the the laws of the game are not are not are not first order anymore so it's like sometimes the world works the way you expect sometimes it doesn't and it's just kind of it's like sometimes the world works the way you expect. Sometimes it doesn't. And it's just kind of insane to watch. There's a couple games that kind of do something that it reminds me of.
门只是有点像在闪烁，进进出出，整个事情太疯狂了，你真的，我们在这里通过音频无法公正地评价它，但去节目笔记看视频，它只是相当，我见过很多关于 Doom 的奇怪事情，比如他们通过白日梦传递它，你有一种非常奇怪的，你知道，那种迷幻的视角，但这真的把它提升到了一个新的水平，就像你正在藐视，游戏的规则不再是第一顺序了，所以就像有时世界按照你期望的方式运作，有时它不运作，这只是有点，有时世界按照你期望的方式运作。有时它不运作。这看起来简直太疯狂了。有几个游戏有点像它，让我想起了它。
So I actually have seen this one before. And like you're saying, it's kind of weird because it looks like you're playing the game 90 percent of the time or whatever but then occasionally something happens uh that is different so like you're looking one way you turn around and face the other way and then when you turn back the world is completely different like you're not in the same same place or like the world has shifted because it's just it's generative so it's just doing the whole thing sort of like on the fly so you almost convince yourself it's right and there's a game i think it's super liminal i don't know if you've played this that has stuff like this like you you can go
所以我确实以前见过这个。就像你说的，它有点奇怪，因为看起来你 90% 的时间都在玩游戏，但偶尔会发生一些不同的事情，比如你看着一个方向，你转过身面对另一个方向，然后当你转回来时，世界完全不同了，就像你不在同一个地方，或者世界已经转移了，因为它只是生成式的，所以它只是在即时做整个事情，所以你几乎说服自己它是对的，有一个游戏，我想是 Superliminal，我不知道你有没有玩过，它有这样的东西，比如你可以穿过
through a door and then when you come back through the door like you're not in the same place it's sort of i don't call like non-euclidean or whatever. And it kind of plays with the sort of perspective. And so if something changes size in your perspective, it changes size in real life as well, in the game as well. And so there's all these things you can do where it sort of subverts your expectation of a game modeling reality. And it doesn't mean it's not fun to play.
一扇门，然后当你穿过门回来时，你不在同一个地方，它有点像非欧几里得之类的。它有点玩弄那种视角。所以如果某样东西在你的视角中改变了大小，它在现实生活中也会改变大小，在游戏中也是如此。所以你可以做所有这些事情，它颠覆了你对游戏模拟现实的期望。这并不意味着它不好玩。
It's just, it can be very fun i don't know in these cases maybe it probably wouldn't be very fun um but it it is just like this weird twist to your brain yeah totally i'm pretty sure you can't get much beyond the first or second level in this i mean this is like some academic exercise um but uh uh but yeah i just think there's something there's something just kind of wild i mean it's it's uh definitely something i've never seen before where someone tries to like imitate an entire engine of a game with a neural network and then see what happens people with too much time on their head no i'm just well you know people with too much time on their hands? No, I'm just kidding. Well, you know, people with too much money in their hands, right? Because of the AI hype cycle.
它只是，它可以非常有趣，我不知道在这些情况下，也许它可能不会非常有趣，但它只是对你的大脑的一种奇怪的扭曲。是的，完全正确，我很确定你在这个游戏中无法超越第一或第二关，我的意思是这就像某种学术练习，但，但是的，我只是认为有一些东西，有一些东西简直太疯狂了，我的意思是，这绝对是我从未见过的，有人试图用神经网络模仿整个游戏引擎，然后看看会发生什么。人们有太多的时间，不，我只是，好吧，你知道，人们有太多的时间？不，我只是开个玩笑。好吧，你知道，人们手头有太多的钱，对吧？因为 AI 的炒作周期。
Oh, there we go. Yeah, I mean, maybe that should be episode 178. So we'll get sent some our way. We'll try some of this stuff. Yeah, that's right. Yeah, we're currently raising, we have a new model. It's called CLAWED, C-l-a-w-e-d it absolutely does not just call claude under the hood please give us 50 million dollars oh i yeah i i've seen some of
哦，来了。是的，我的意思是，也许那应该是第 178 期。所以我们会收到一些。我们会尝试一些这样的东西。是的，没错。是的，我们目前正在筹集资金，我们有一个新模型。它叫 CLAWED，C-l-a-w-e-d，它绝对不是在底层调用 Claude，请给我们 5000 万美元。哦，我，我见过一些
these accusations going around about people just calling other models and saying yeah okay anyway we're moving on uh this is the uh the ai gossip i guess yeah that's right my next article is a kind of related to the previous one your company needs junior developers uh and so again i guess a bit by is this something i i push for all the time i work it's a strongly held personal belief and uh and so um the idea here a lot of places i think you can fall into the trap of hey we want to hire a senior person the you know inside joke i guess it goes around is like you read resumes and it's like hey you need 10 years of experience with you know a tool that came out two years ago and it's like everybody needs to hire the utmost expert in the field and in practice that's not really true most of the time
这些指控到处流传，关于人们只是调用其他模型并说，是的，好吧，无论如何，我们继续，这是 AI 八卦，我想。是的，没错，我的下一篇文章与前一篇有关，你的公司需要初级开发人员，所以再次，我想有点偏见，这是我一直推动的事情，我在工作中，这是一个根深蒂固的个人信念，所以，嗯，这里的想法是，我认为很多地方你可能会陷入陷阱，嘿，我们想雇佣一个高级人员，你知道，内部笑话，我想它流传开来，就像你读简历，就像，嘿，你需要 10 年的经验，使用一个两年前才出来的工具，就像每个人都需要雇佣该领域最顶尖的专家，而在实践中，大多数时候这并不是真的，
that isn't it's not to say that there's never a good idea to hire senior people but i feel by default most folks have this belief that like hey hey, we're high velocity, the way to like, keep this up is just keep adding people at the same level of the team or above the level of the team to bring them up. And in some cases, that may be true. But I have found that often, there's a number of first and second order effects that come from hiring junior developers you know and i'm not even talking about like budget you know money reasons i'll leave all that aside hiring junior people and being able to train them like helps them sort of uh they they're more uh plastic towards you know how stuff is being done and learning if, you know, they're inquisitive.
这并不是说雇佣高级人员从来都不是一个好主意，但我感觉默认情况下，大多数人都有这种信念，嘿，我们是高速度的，保持这种状态的方法就是不断在团队层面或团队层面之上增加人员来提升他们。在某些情况下，这可能是真的。但我发现，通常，雇佣初级开发人员会产生许多第一和第二顺序的影响，你知道，我甚至不是在谈论预算，你知道金钱原因，我会把所有这些放在一边，雇佣初级人员并能够培训他们，帮助他们，他们对事情是如何完成的以及学习方面更具可塑性，如果，你知道，他们是好奇的。
And it's not to say that they won't express their own opinions or bring changes. They often will and sort of say, hey, I learned it this way or why not this? And they ask a lot of questions and through those questions, I think can come learning. But they don't come in with as many preconceived notions of this is the only way to do things, or every time I've done it is this way, or hey, we first need to reconform everything you've done to my way of doing it. And then we'll start making progress. But also putting the, you know, more senior developers into the mode of teaching and by teaching, they're learning, they're having to synthesize concepts and simplify stuff, like we were talking about before cognitive burden if you're the only one coding maybe it doesn't matter so much because the context is always loaded in your head but the
这并不是说他们不会表达自己的观点或带来改变。他们经常会，并说，嘿，我是这样学的，或者为什么不是这样？他们问很多问题，通过这些问题，我认为可以带来学习。但他们没有带着那么多先入为主的观念进来，比如这是做事情的唯一方法，或者我每次做的时候都是这样，或者嘿，我们首先需要把你做的一切重新调整为我的做事方式。然后我们才会开始取得进展。但也要把，你知道，更高级的开发人员置于教学模式中，通过教学，他们正在学习，他们必须综合概念并简化东西，就像我们之前谈论的认知负担，如果你是唯一一个编码的人，也许这并不重要，因为上下文总是加载在你的脑子里，但
minute you have to share that context with someone else who's also making changes right now you start to like help each other and improve and um also i think making sure that the expectation is known to senior engineers that there will be junior engineers and that they will bear some of the responsibility for helping to onboard teach and you know show them not that they have to become managers but that everyone on the team has a responsibility to help you know those who are trying to learn or asking questions and i think that again these first and second order that you have someone who is contributing who can grow and can like you know sort of become the the team member that you need also gives like a sense of a narrative arc
当你必须与现在也在做改变的其他人分享那个上下文时，你开始互相帮助并改进，而且，嗯，我也认为确保高级工程师知道会有初级工程师，并且他们将承担一些帮助入职、教学的责任，你知道，向他们展示，不是说他们必须成为经理，而是团队中的每个人都有责任帮助那些试图学习或提出问题的人，我认为再次，这些第一和第二顺序，你有一个正在做出贡献的人，他可以成长，可以，你知道，成为你需要的团队成员，也给团队一种叙事弧，
to the team right like that we were here and now we're there and like look at the growth and so for just a host of reasons i think it's a really important thing to be hiring junior engineers to bring them on to have them grow and learn. And then also sometimes projects go through phases and the project of your phase may be, hey, it's not insane growth right now. We're not able to hire a ton of people. Because of that, some senior engineers may need to or want to move on to other companies or other projects or other things because there isn't a lot left for them to sort of grow, but there's still a lot to be done. And this is when junior engineers can come in. And for them, that work is super suitable. Whereas for a senior engineer, it may be difficult to justify, you know, the continued sort of like, you know Patrick and I are really invested in growing engineers. I mean, the whole point of this show when we started it so many years ago was that and sort of the future of the field. I think that engineers have been hit with some really big whammies. The first thing they've been hit by is just exploding college tuition costs, right?
对吧，我们曾经在这里，现在我们在那里，看看成长，所以出于各种原因，我认为雇佣初级工程师，让他们加入，让他们成长和学习是一件非常重要的事情。然后有时项目会经历阶段，你的阶段项目可能是，嘿，现在不是疯狂增长。我们无法雇佣大量的人。正因为如此，一些高级工程师可能需要或想要转到其他公司或其他项目或其他事情，因为没有多少东西留给他们成长，但还有很多事情要做。这就是初级工程师可以进来的地方。对他们来说，这项工作非常合适。而对于高级工程师来说，可能很难证明，你知道，持续的，你知道，Patrick 和我真的致力于培养工程师。我的意思是，我们多年前开始这个节目时的全部意义就是那个，以及该领域的未来。我认为工程师们受到了一些非常大的打击。他们受到的第一件事就是大学学费的暴涨，对吧？
Then you get hit with the pandemic and all of your mentors being, you know, not being around. And now there's all the layoffs and companies saying, I was in a meeting. There was a Austin like engineering leadership meeting that I was at. And this person was saying that, like, hey, you know, we just need to get rid of like 80% of our company like Twitter did and just keep like the 20% super productive people. And the thing is, that will work in the short term for your company. But there's a tragedy of the commons there where like you're kind of like, it's like when you buy roses from HEB or from your grocery store and they look great, but they don't have roots. And so, you know, that these roses will not live very long. They're already dead. Yeah, that's right. Like, like the cat is dead in the box. And so,
然后你受到大流行的打击，你所有的导师都不在身边。现在有所有的裁员和公司说，我在一个会议上。有一个奥斯汀工程领导会议，我在那里。这个人说，嘿，你知道，我们只需要像 Twitter 那样摆脱我们公司 80% 的人，只保留 20% 超级高效的人。问题是，这在短期内对你的公司有效。但那里有一个公地悲剧，就像你买 HEB 或杂货店的玫瑰，它们看起来很棒，但它们没有根。所以，你知道，这些玫瑰活不了多久。它们已经死了。是的，没错。就像，猫在盒子里死了。所以，
and so like, yeah, you're without roots, like it's just not, it's just a temporary facade. And so without roots, it's just a temporary facade. And so I do worry a lot about junior devs just not having a safe place to land. What do you think is going to happen, Patrick? Do you think that if people keep focusing on senior devs, do you think that people are going to get dissatisfied? There's going to be a generational gap or uh what i mean leaving aside uh fundamental pivotal shifts from you know ai or whatever um i think it's a slightly different topic i think this is where uh and and this will get somewhat i guess a little maybe controversial but i think this is one of the
所以，是的，没有根，这只是一个暂时的门面。所以没有根，这只是一个暂时的门面。所以我确实非常担心初级开发人员没有一个安全的地方可以落脚。你认为会发生什么，Patrick？你认为如果人们继续关注高级开发人员，你认为人们会感到不满吗？会有代沟，或者，我的意思是，撇开来自 AI 或什么的根本性关键转变，我认为这是一个稍微不同的主题，我认为这就是，呃，这会变得有点，我想有点争议，但我认为这是
benefits of having capitalist markets is like i think companies that will hire junior devs and invest in training them will have a market advantage and so you know two companies participating in the same so that company that you mentioned just as an example like i want to lay off all these junior people they're not really pulling their own weight right now. We overhired our fault, whatever. Those people are going to go somewhere. And if not, they might self-organize and kind of learn their own thing and build up a competitor or do something better because they kind of see what wasn't working at the previous company. And so this is where I'm a believer that, you know, having the competition, companies that do this will end up winning out over companies that don't. Companies
拥有资本主义市场的好处之一，我认为会雇佣初级开发人员并投资培训他们的公司将拥有市场优势，所以，你知道，两家公司参与同一个，所以你提到的那家公司，作为一个例子，我想裁掉所有这些初级人员，他们现在并没有真正发挥自己的作用。我们雇佣过多了，我们的错，无论如何。这些人会去某个地方。如果不是，他们可能会自我组织并学习自己的东西，建立一个竞争对手或做一些更好的事情，因为他们看到了前一家公司哪里出了问题。所以这就是为什么我相信，你知道，拥有竞争，做这件事的公司最终会胜过不做这件事的公司。公司
are willing to teach and hire. Again, like I said, I think they have better practices. And that's not to say in some extreme example that, like you said, somebody could do this and in the short term, it works amazing. But then, and you know, hopefully it doesn't happen. But what if you have a team of super high functioning, three people, they're working at 110% capacity. it doesn't happen but what if you have a team of super high functioning three people they're working at 110 capacity that doesn't make sense i know but they're working 100 capacity super optimal you think you're a genius and then one of them uh i mean i work with people we're getting not that old but up in age have a heart attack have like you know family emergency and they literally stop working for six months and there's no redundancy there's no backup like is your company going to like close close shop
愿意教书和雇佣。再说一次，就像我说的，我认为他们有更好的做法。这并不是说在某些极端例子中，就像你说的，有人可以这样做，在短期内，它运作得非常棒。但然后，你知道，希望它不会发生。但如果你有一个超级高效的团队，三个人，他们以 110% 的能力工作。这不合理，我知道，但他们以 100% 的能力工作，超级优化，你认为你是天才，然后其中一个，我的意思是，我和人们一起工作，我们没有那么老，但年纪大了，心脏病发作，有家庭紧急情况，他们实际上停止工作了六个月，没有冗余，没有备份，你的公司会倒闭吗
because you were that's kind of i guess the equivalent in financing is people do leverage they use all this leverage and it works great until it doesn't and so you seem really genius i guess it's equivalent what you're saying about the roses already cut. Yeah, it's really genius. You're making all this money on leverage. But as soon as, you know, the tide turns even a little bit, you crash really fast because everything is magnified. Right, right. And even if like you might say, well, I will let other companies hire and and skill up junior engineers and then i will just hire those people when they become senior engineers but i think the problem with that is you need to transfer
因为你，我想这在财务上相当于人们使用杠杆，他们使用所有这些杠杆，它运作得很好，直到它不运作，所以你看起来真的很天才，我想这相当于你说的关于已经剪掉的玫瑰。是的，这真的很天才。你通过杠杆赚了所有这些钱。但一旦，你知道，潮水稍微转动一点，你就崩溃得非常快，因为一切都被放大了。对，对。即使你可能会说，好吧，我会让其他公司雇佣和培养初级工程师，然后当他们成为高级工程师时，我就会雇佣这些人，但我认为问题在于你需要转移
knowledge within your company you know i don't think it's not as fungible as people would hope and so uh and so that i don't think that strategy will work either yeah i mean you still have to teach them this specific most companies still have quite specific things so even if you say i will let other people train them and then we hire them you don't have a culture of training people because you don't do it very obviously but hire them back and then you're going to have a difficulty getting them to adapt and so you're going to go through a lot more pain and suffering yep yeah exactly um all right so um oh on to mine so mine are a couple of libraries that let you do um real-time text-to-speech which is now becoming basically an open source commodity which is kind
公司内部的知识，你知道，我不认为它不像人们希望的那样可替代，所以，呃，所以我认为那个策略也不会奏效。是的，我的意思是，你仍然必须教他们这个特定的，大多数公司仍然有相当具体的东西，所以即使你说我会让其他人培训他们，然后我们雇佣他们，你没有培训人的文化，因为你没有非常明显地做，但把他们雇回来，然后你将很难让他们适应，所以你将经历更多的痛苦和折磨。是的，完全正确，嗯，好的，所以，嗯，哦，到我的了，所以我的是一些让你做实时文本转语音的库，这现在基本上正在成为开源商品，这有点
of amazing so so you can actually um and i'll add a third one to it that just came out uh this morning but um you can actually have a conversation with an ai um an open source ai in real time uh and uh that just blows my mind um like you can you can uh talk to it it'll talk back you can interrupt it and say hey i want to talk about something else like all these things that we saw in that um open ai demo about maybe six months ago a year ago are now becoming a commodity um and uh here's here's a few examples of libraries that do this um but yeah, I think the progress is just absolutely astounding. I mean, it's actually really hard to keep up with the technology.
令人惊奇，所以你可以，嗯，我会再加上第三个，今天早上刚出来的，但你可以实际上与 AI 进行对话，一个开源 AI，实时地，这让我大吃一惊，就像你可以与它交谈，它会回话，你可以打断它并说，嘿，我想谈谈别的事情，就像我们在那个 OpenAI 演示中看到的，大约六个月前，一年前，现在正在成为商品，这里有一些做这个的库的例子，但是的，我认为进步绝对是惊人的。我的意思是，实际上很难跟上技术的发展。
It's just moving so fast. But this is a really big milestone, and a few different libraries have kind of reached it in more or less the same time. With the speed of some of this and like you were joking about earlier but i kind of find myself thinking about it sometimes companies there's a lot of untapped potential and sort of developing companies around some of these things and just you know replacing uh stuff within bounds but i think defining those bounds is really important like you know making sure that there are some i don't call them guardrails or whatever around how some of this stuff is done
它发展得太快了。但这确实是一个非常大的里程碑，几个不同的库在或多或少相同的时间达到了它。随着其中一些的速度，就像你之前开玩笑的那样，但我有时会发现自己会想到它，公司有很多未开发的潜力，在其中一些事情周围开发公司，只是，你知道，在范围内替换东西，但我认为定义这些范围非常重要，比如，你知道，确保有一些，我不称它们为护栏或什么的，围绕其中一些事情是如何完成的
but also it's got to be somewhat difficult to you know say you're going to build and do an integration with one of these you know models that came out and then to just like three or four months in potentially a completely different way of doing or a different architecture just moves the goal posts and then you got to decide like do we ship on this old thing or do we like completely redo and move to the new thing and then you end up in this constant cycle of like uh you know oh man i just got completely you know blown away by whatever the next release from whomever is yeah right i mean you know a good example of this is like the text to image stuff where you know wasn't really that commercially practical because the images were just not that good i mean they
但这也一定相当困难，你知道，说你要构建并与这些模型之一进行集成，然后仅仅三四个月后，一种完全不同的做事方式或不同的架构移动了目标柱，然后你必须决定，我们是在这个旧东西上发布，还是我们完全重做并转向新东西，然后你最终陷入这种持续的循环，比如，呃，你知道，哦天哪，我刚刚被无论谁的下一个版本完全吹走了。是的，对，我的意思是，你知道，一个很好的例子是文本转图像的东西，你知道，它并不是真正商业实用的，因为图像并不那么好，我的意思是它们
were fun to look at but like you'd obviously know that this was computer generated and and it basically you know within the span of 12 maybe 18 months it went from from that to like you literally like maybe okay so i take that experts can tell but like you and i can't tell if you see a photo of a person like a profile photo we can't tell if that's a real person or not and and that is just wild i mean if your product um was was kind of based on one thing like you it just opens up a ton of product opportunities to your point yeah there was all that stuff like oh they're not good at text earrings won't be symmetrical you know too many fingers and you're right they were kind of funny to look at and they looked plausible and then now you're right i see pictures posted
看起来很有趣，但你显然知道这是计算机生成的，它基本上，你知道，在 12 到 18 个月的时间里，它从那样变成了，你字面上，也许好吧，专家可以分辨，但你和我无法分辨，如果你看到一个人的照片，比如个人资料照片，我们无法分辨那是不是一个真人，这简直太疯狂了，我的意思是，如果你的产品是基于一件事的，它只是打开了大量的产品机会，说到你的点，是的，有所有那些东西，哦，它们不擅长文本，耳环不会对称，你知道，手指太多，你是对的，它们看起来很有趣，看起来很合理，然后现在你是对的，我看到发布的图片
in some of the sites like oh look at this ai trash and i'm like i i it you know if i really stare at it it looks off but there's a lot of commercial photography that's airbrushed or whatever that also can look off or not natural so i think it's like you said it's a sort of uh you know whatever maybe some experts saying these aren't good but they actually are very convincing a lot of times um and it's really only the fact that the situation is so improbable like oh a cell phone snapshot of you know an elephant parachuting into my backyard like okay probably that didn't actually happen so it must be fake but not it's not actually something in the scene that tells you that's not realistic right right and uh the thing too is yeah i mean if if if you
在某些网站上，比如“看这些AI垃圾”，我会觉得，你知道，如果我真的盯着看，它看起来有点不对劲，但有很多商业摄影也是经过喷枪处理之类的，看起来也可能不对劲或不自然，所以我认为就像你说的，这是一种，你知道，可能有些专家说这些不好，但它们实际上在很多时候非常有说服力，嗯，而且真正的原因只是情况太不可思议了，比如“一张手机快照，拍到一只大象跳伞降落到我的后院”，好吧，这可能并没有真正发生，所以它一定是假的，但并不是场景中有什么东西告诉你它不真实，对吧？对，而且还有一点是，是的，我的意思是，如果
if you're in the mindset of i wonder if this is real or not because someone told me it's fake well then you're gonna have a very discerning eye right but if you're just on the internet browsing you're not you're not you know you're not in that type two mode of thinking, you're just consuming content. And, and I think you will just, I think many people will just look at fake images and just think they're real. Uh, like all these stock images, you go to like some random startup that just paid like someone on Fiverr to build a website. Right. And there's like stock images of people just having fun around a computer i bet if if you replace those with fake images most people wouldn't
如果你处于“我想知道这是真的还是假的”这种心态，因为有人告诉我它是假的，那么你就会有非常敏锐的眼光，对吧？但如果你只是在网上浏览，你并没有处于那种“第二类思维模式”，你只是在消费内容。而且，我认为你只会，我认为很多人只会看假图片并认为它们是真的。呃，就像所有这些库存图片，你去某个随机的初创公司，他们只是付钱给Fiverr上的某个人来建立一个网站。对。然后上面有人们在电脑周围玩得很开心的库存图片，我敢打赌，如果你用假图片替换它们，大多数人不会
know yeah and there are some ethics problems i will say as well looking at everything with the discerning eye causes his own problem because there's plenty of actual images taken that look implausible or seem unrealistic as well and there are totally legit for variety of things so you could enter conspiratorial whatever like yeah i saw a video of this bad thing happening but it's it's just fake like it doesn't look real there's no way that really happened oh interesting yeah i mean that's a that's a different direction i hadn't thought about is if there's a real event, like we're at 912 today. Yesterday was 911.
知道。是的，而且我也得说存在一些伦理问题，用敏锐的眼光看待一切也会导致它自己的问题，因为有很多拍摄的真实图像看起来也难以置信或显得不真实，而且它们对于各种事情来说是完全合法的，所以你可能会陷入阴谋论之类的，比如“是的，我看到了这个坏事发生的视频，但它是假的，它看起来不真实，这不可能真的发生”。哦，有趣，是的，我的意思是，这是一个我没想到的不同方向，如果有一个真实的事件，比如我们今天在9月12日。昨天是9月11日。
So like, yeah, I mean, if I'm reading Twitter and I see like some big terrorist attack, my first reaction might be like, that's a fake picture or something. You know, it's kind of wild. All right. So moving on to book of the show. Patrick, what is your book of the show? Book of the show is not a book. Cheater. Warning, tool of the show is not a tool either. So yeah, we got to rename these sections, man. All right. I thought I must have talked about this before, but I Googled through the show notes and I didn't see it. So if I have, I apologize.
所以，是的，我的意思是，如果我在读Twitter，看到一些大的恐怖袭击，我的第一反应可能是“那是一张假照片”之类的。你知道，这有点疯狂。好吧。那么继续节目推荐书目。帕特里克，你推荐的书是什么？节目推荐书目不是一本书。作弊者。警告，节目推荐工具也不是工具。所以是的，我们得给这些部分改名，伙计。好吧。我以为我之前一定谈过这个，但我用谷歌搜索了节目笔记，没看到它。所以如果我谈过，我道歉。
I have never heard of this, so I think you're good. So this is one of those, I know it's like fairly popular now, but I run across fairly popular, like million subscriber YouTube channels all the time that I've never heard about before. It's just a million isn't what it used to be or something. I sound like an old man now. All right, anyways, so Thought Empporium is a guy who does i guess like just call like hobbyist science research my hero like i wish i wish i could do this stuff like i wish i could
我从来没听说过这个，所以我认为你没问题。所以这是其中之一，我知道它现在相当受欢迎，但我一直遇到相当受欢迎的、拥有百万订阅者的YouTube频道，我以前从未听说过。只是“一百万”已经不是以前的样子了，或者别的什么。我现在听起来像个老头子。好吧，无论如何，Thought Emporium是一个做，我猜就是所谓的“业余科学研究”的人，我的英雄，我真希望我能做这些事情，我真希望我能
make money just poking around like random stuff in my lab and like i want to say close to probably half of the stuff he does like i have at one time or another done played with or sort of so it's very fascinating there's a bunch of uh sort of one-off projects um and long-term projects that he's working on including topics like genetic engineering um he was recently trying to grow neurons to play doom so how do you like grow neurons in a petri dish hook them up to electrodes hook that up to a computer and make them play doom and not your garage that's not exactly right because this garage is kind of fancy but not in a multi-million dollar biomedical research lab either the one i linked is just him and his friends like sometimes come up with memes i think they released one yesterday i was like you know everybody always jokes what did you take this photo with a potato um just him and his friends like sometimes come up with memes i think they released one yesterday
靠在实验室里摆弄随机的东西赚钱，我想说他做的东西里大概有一半，我曾经在某个时候玩过或做过，所以这非常迷人，有很多呃，那种一次性的项目，以及他正在进行的长期项目，包括遗传工程等主题，他最近试图培养神经元来玩《毁灭战士》，所以你是怎么在培养皿中培养神经元，把它们连接到电极上，连接到电脑上，让它们玩《毁灭战士》的，而不是在你的车库里，那不完全对，因为这个车库有点高级，但也不是在数百万美元的生物医学研究实验室里，我链接的那个只是他和他的朋友们，有时会想出模因，我想他们昨天发布了一个，我说“你知道每个人总是开玩笑说，你用土豆拍的这张照片吗”，只是他和他的朋友们，有时会想出模因，我想他们昨天发布了一个
it was like you know everybody always jokes what did you take this photo with a potato and so he actually built cameras out of potatoes um not like a potato hooked up to a camera like the whole camera is a potato um and so like the potato is a pinhole uh and you use the flesh to sort of get a negative image okay anyways the one i linked to in the show notes you can check it out is a single use emergency thermite hot dog cooker so what would you need it to do if you needed to cook exactly one hot dog like in an emergency situation in a single use container and it's just like him figuring out like in a moderately serious engineering like how would i what is the best way to do this like how would i use heat to cook the hotdog should i cook it like by itself should i cook it in a liquid
就像“你知道每个人总是开玩笑说，你用土豆拍的这张照片吗”，所以他真的用土豆做了相机，不是那种连接到相机的土豆，而是整个相机就是一个土豆，所以土豆是一个针孔，你用果肉来得到负像。好吧，无论如何，我在节目笔记中链接的那个，你可以去看看，是一个一次性紧急铝热剂热狗烹饪器，所以如果你需要在紧急情况下烹饪正好一个热狗，在一个一次性容器里，你需要它做什么，这就像他弄清楚，以一种适度认真的工程方式，我该怎么做，什么是最好的方法，我应该用热量来烹饪热狗吗，我应该单独烹饪它吗，我应该把它放在液体里烹饪吗
you know is this actually going to work how safe is this you know could i make the could you make a product out of it and so if you've never checked them out uh definitely do there was a lot of biohacking initially like you know i'm going to inject the genetically modifying materials into myself and do crazy stuff um nowadays a little less but another one that my kids really liked was, is mummy yummy? So let's go through the full process of making like a mummified chicken from the store, grocery store, like legit. We're going to go into reading hieroglyphics and making our own hieroglyphic statements. Do the full mummification process with authentic old recipes and then taste various parts of the mummification
你知道这真的行得通吗，这有多安全，你知道我能从中制造出一个产品吗，所以如果你从来没看过他们，呃，一定要看。最初有很多生物黑客行为，比如“我要把基因改造材料注射到自己体内，做疯狂的事情”，现在少了一些，但我孩子们真的很喜欢的另一个是，“木乃伊好吃吗？”所以让我们完成从杂货店制作木乃伊鸡的完整过程，像合法的。我们要去阅读象形文字，并制作我们自己的象形文字陈述。用正宗的古老食谱完成完整的木乃伊化过程，然后品尝木乃伊化的各个部分
fluids and things and determine if mummy is yummy is that healthy i mean or is that sanitary so nowadays it would be formaldehyde and you definitely eat formaldehyde but it turns out in ancient egypt they didn't have formaldehyde so you actually could use most of the stuff so i won't spoil but if you think it is intriguing to find out if mummy is yummy you're in the right place okay yeah this is awesome i think i think uh this is one of these things where you know 40 hours of my life later i'm like how did i get on this youtube channel uh mine's the opposite so i watch this and then i find myself on ebay like how could i replicate what this guy is doing like i have so many questions yeah the youtube to amazon pipeline is strong um my book of the show is a project that i started with a friend of mine um called
液体和东西，并确定木乃伊是否好吃，那健康吗，或者那卫生吗？所以现在那将是甲醛，你肯定会吃甲醛，但事实证明在古埃及他们没有甲醛，所以你实际上可以使用大部分东西，所以我不会剧透，但如果你觉得找出木乃伊是否好吃很有趣，你就来对地方了。好的，是的，这太棒了，我想，我想呃，这是其中之一，你知道，我生命中40小时后，我想“我是怎么进入这个YouTube频道的”，我的正好相反，所以我看了这个，然后我发现自己在eBay上，我想“我怎么能复制这个家伙正在做的事情”，我有这么多问题。是的，YouTube到亚马逊的管道很强大，嗯，我的节目推荐书目是我和一个朋友开始的一个项目，叫做
novel minds and the idea was there's all these public domain books. A lot of them are required reading for kids. Even the ones that aren't, a lot of them are really good, like War of the Worlds, like classics, right? So I thought, could I use AI to turn them into sort of, I think the word is graphic novels. I mean, not, not literally a comic book, but just a picture book. So there's just a lot of pictures, you know, the cover is
Novel Minds，这个想法是，有所有这些公共领域的书籍。其中很多是孩子们的必读书目。即使是那些不是必读的，很多也非常棒，比如《世界大战》，比如经典，对吧？所以我心想，我能用AI把它们变成某种，我想这个词是“图画小说”。我的意思是，不是，不是字面意义上的漫画书，而只是一本图画书。所以有很多图片，你知道，封面是
totally redone. And so we did this. So, um, by the time folks listen to this show, there'll be 30 books on this site. Uh, I think at the time of the recording, there's maybe seven or so. But you can basically grab them all for free. If you're on Apple, it will just open in Apple Books naturally. If you're on Android, you'll have to get an EPUB reader, but there's plenty of them for free. And you can read all these classic books with tons of pictures. We tried to do roughly a picture every like 400 words or so. And there's a bunch of technology. I actually gave a talk on how this works that's recorded. And I posted the talk on LinkedIn if folks want to watch that for more technical depth.
完全重做的。所以我们做了这个。所以，嗯，当人们听到这个节目时，这个网站上会有30本书。呃，我想在录制时，大概有七本左右。但你基本上可以免费获取它们。如果你在苹果设备上，它会自然地在Apple Books中打开。如果你在安卓设备上，你必须找一个EPUB阅读器，但有很多免费的。你可以阅读所有这些带有大量图片的经典书籍。我们尝试大约每400个字左右放一张图片。而且有很多技术。我实际上做了一个关于它是如何工作的演讲，已经录制下来了。如果人们想看更多技术深度，我把演讲发布在LinkedIn上了。
But if you have kids who are in school who are have to read these books, you could give your kids or your friends, your friends, kids, copies of these versions, all the text is exactly the same. We we haven't changed any of the words. We just added a ton of pictures. I did not know about this until right now. So I'm actually scrolling through one at present. This is really cool. The style is very consistent. The main character doesn't seem to be, I'm looking at around the world in 80 days,
但如果你有在学校的孩子必须读这些书，你可以给你的孩子或你的朋友，你朋友的孩子，这些版本的副本，所有的文字完全一样。我们没有改变任何单词。我们只是添加了大量的图片。直到现在我才知道这个。所以我现在实际上正在浏览其中一本。这真的很酷。风格非常一致。主角似乎不是，我正在看《环游世界八十天》，
but the main character doesn't seem to be super consistent between them. But there used to be books when I was younger, they were like, there's like every other page, there was like a hand-drawn illustration. And then they were the like synopsis. Like they were kind of, I don't know,
但主角在它们之间似乎不是超级一致。但我年轻的时候有那种书，它们就像，每隔一页，就有一张手绘插图。然后它们是那种概要。就像它们有点，我不知道，
10% of the full book or whatever. they were kind of i don't know 10 of the full book or whatever they were like concise oh yeah yeah so okay a couple of things so one uh the version that patrick's you're looking at right now is is an older version oh okay we did fix the consistency um in the newer version uh we basically um used something like a vector database. Foreshadowing. But we kind of encoded a representation of each of the characters. And then when a character is referenced, we added that representation back in. And so now the version that will be out when we publish the show actually is pretty
全书的10%之类的。它们有点，我不知道，全书的10%之类的。它们是简洁的。哦，是的，是的，所以好吧，几件事。所以第一，帕特里克你现在正在看的版本是一个旧版本。哦，好的，我们确实修复了一致性，在较新的版本中，我们基本上使用了一些类似向量数据库的东西。伏笔。但我们对每个角色的表示进行了编码。然后当引用一个角色时，我们把那个表示加了回去。所以现在当我们发布节目时出来的版本实际上相当
consistent um but yeah you're right the the first the very first version um was like thematically completely inconsistent like one picture would be black and white the next picture would look like a cartoon next picture would be like a hyper real, you know, and so getting consistency. The second phase was where we got a pretty consistent art style, but the era was all over the place. So like, you know, it'd be 80 days around the world, which was record, which was set around the 1890s, I think. But there would be like a high speed rail picture or a guy with like a rocket launcher you know and so what we did there was uh we also injected the era we figured out the era by scanning the book and then we inject that into every single image prompt um so yeah it's been a really really fun exercise um my goal is ultimately to get these into the kindle store although it's pretty difficult because there's a lot of scammers
一致，嗯，但你是对的，第一个，最初的版本，在主题上完全不一致，一张图片可能是黑白的，下一张图片看起来像卡通，下一张图片看起来像超现实，你知道，所以获得一致性。第二阶段是我们获得了一个相当一致的艺术风格，但时代到处都是。所以，你知道，它可能是《环游世界八十天》，设定在1890年代左右，我想。但会有像高铁的图片，或者一个拿着火箭发射器的人，你知道，所以我们在那里做的是，我们还注入了时代，我们通过扫描书籍弄清楚了时代，然后我们把它注入到每一个图像提示中，所以是的，这是一个非常非常有趣的练习，我的目标最终是把这些放到Kindle商店，尽管这很难，因为有很多骗子
who try to push either fake ai books or public domain books onto the store and so we're running over a couple of barriers just trying to prove to amazon that we're legit um but uh yeah that's it's a fun little book project and i've had an awesome time actually reading these books some of them are a little difficult to read because they're rather old uh but uh a lot of them are awesome this is cool i'm trying to determine how many of these i've read before so can i have another request can you like run the generator to give me summaries so it's like all the pictures but only one percent of the words so that i could uh claim to have read all of these books much more
试图把假AI书籍或公共领域书籍推到商店上，所以我们正面临几个障碍，试图向亚马逊证明我们是合法的，但呃，是的，这是一个有趣的小书籍项目，我实际上度过了一段美好的时光阅读这些书，其中一些很难读，因为它们相当古老，但呃，很多都很棒。这很酷，我正在尝试确定我以前读过多少本，所以我能再提一个要求吗？你能运行生成器给我摘要吗？这样它就是所有的图片，但只有1%的文字，这样我就能声称读过所有这些书，比实际阅读所有这些书要快得多
quickly than actually read all of these that's an interesting idea you know i wonder you know the reason why uh the reason why i didn't change the words is i felt like if it is required reading through someone no yeah there's a test or something bad idea but yeah but but you're right i mean for people who aren't reading it for a grade or anything um we could definitely like summarize every paragraph or do something like that there was a so what i want okay so this is really dumb okay we can move on but uh growing up there was this show wishbone where it was a little dog do you did you watch this show no i never heard of it okay oh my gosh all right this is good all right i'll make it short so just this dog who goes to same same idea like various famous you know plays or books and the the dog is like the you know he goes into the story and then he you know it's like a dog is the main character or whatever in the book
那是个有趣的想法，你知道，我想知道，你知道，我没有改变文字的原因是，我觉得如果它是某人的必读书目，不，是的，有考试之类的，坏主意，但是的，但你是对的，我的意思是，对于那些不是为了成绩而阅读的人，我们绝对可以像总结每一段或者做类似的事情。有一个，所以我想要，好的，这真的很蠢，好的，我们可以继续，但呃，成长过程中有一个节目叫《Wishbone》，它是一只小狗，你，你看过这个节目吗？不，我从来没听说过。好的，天哪，好吧，这很好，好吧，我会长话短说，所以只是这只狗，他去，同样的想法，各种著名的，你知道，戏剧或书籍，然后这只狗就像，你知道，他进入故事，然后他，你知道，就像一只狗是主角，或者书里的什么东西
but they're just acting out the book in a 30-minute show and so you get the arc of you know the book the main idea the gist in 30 minutes for kids just like teach them about different worlds and different you know a moral story or whatever but i okay that won't make sense if you know but that's what i want is like the the wishbone like the hey i could hold a conversation with someone and unless we were doing like a book club they would believe that i had read the book and i will have benefited from the you know analogy or the you know whatever the you know book is trying to get without all of the dialogue that happens between you know characters that like you said if it's required reading it may be very important to read i'm not trying to denigrate old books but i also know that i won't commit that
但他们只是在30分钟的节目中演出了这本书，所以你得到了书的弧线，你知道，书的主要思想，要点，在30分钟内为孩子们，只是教他们关于不同的世界和不同的，你知道，道德故事之类的，但我，好的，如果你知道的话，那没意义，但这就是我想要的，就像《Wishbone》那样，嘿，我可以和某人进行对话，除非我们是在做读书俱乐部，否则他们会相信我读过这本书，并且我将从，你知道，类比或，你知道，无论什么，你知道，书试图传达的东西中受益，而没有所有发生在，你知道，角色之间的对话，就像你说的，如果是必读书目，阅读它可能非常重要，我不是想诋毁旧书，但我也知道我不会投入那个
time yeah it's a great idea um maybe by the time you publish a show i'll be able to do that i mean one simple thing would be you know take each chunk which is around i think it's 4 000 characters take each chunk uh that's being used to make an image and summarize that chunk down to like 200 characters all right i'm excited this is cool i don't know how you're going to become rich and and uh become the financier of the uh the biomedical research lab but uh we'll work on that i'm talking to was it tony stark all right time for tool of the show yeah if you want to help us oh sorry go next
时间。是的，这是个好主意，嗯，也许当你发布节目时，我能做到这一点，我的意思是，一个简单的事情是，你知道，取每一块，大约是4000个字符，取每一块，被用来制作图像，并将那块总结到大约200个字符。好的，我很兴奋，这很酷。我不知道你将如何变得富有，并成为生物医学研究实验室的资助者，但呃，我们会努力的。我在和托尼·斯塔克说话吗？好的，节目工具时间。是的，如果你想帮助我们，哦，抱歉，下一个
tony stark you can subscribe to us on patreon uh patreon.com slash programming throwdown okay that was actually legit sorry i was skipping over but that is really cool i'm excited i have to move on because i feel bad about myself for not contributing to society speaking of which my tool of the show not being a tool and a way to uh not waste time to uh improve your uh your brain is escape simulator i think i mentioned before playing some escape games i recently actually picked this one up in a humble bundle i i didn't you know kind of think too much of it but it's actually like it was pretty cool and just so much content in this game um so escape simulator it's kind of what it says on the box it's an escape
托尼·斯塔克，你可以在Patreon上订阅我们，patreon.com/programmingthrowdown。好的，那实际上是合法的，抱歉，我跳过了，但这真的很酷，我很兴奋，我必须继续，因为我对自己没有为社会做出贡献感到难过。说到这里，我的节目工具不是一个工具，而是一种不浪费时间，来提高你的大脑的方法，是《Escape Simulator》，我想我之前提到过玩一些逃脱游戏，我最近实际上在Humble Bundle中买了这一个，我没有，你知道，想太多，但它实际上，它非常酷，而且这个游戏里有太多的内容，所以《Escape Simulator》，它有点像包装盒上说的，它是一个逃脱
room simulator and they themselves have a lot of content for levels that you can play but they also have a big fan base that is making games of various complexities for you to play and i just i really enjoyed doing it i've been i've been playing i've not come anywhere close to beating it because i refuse to you hint use hints um and my daughter sometimes sits and we play together and uh you know i personally not my kids are pretty smart but like way to be impressed with your kids is have them shout out an answer to something and you can't figure out why that is the answer you try it and it works and then have them try to explain to you like how the puzzle had that answer. They can't like, they just intuit it,
房间模拟器，他们自己有很多关卡内容供你玩，但他们也有一个庞大的粉丝群，正在制作各种复杂程度的游戏供你玩，我真的很喜欢这样做，我一直在玩，我离通关还差得远，因为我拒绝使用提示，而且我的女儿有时会坐下来，我们一起玩，呃，你知道，我个人，不是我的孩子们很聪明，但像给你的孩子们留下深刻印象的方法是让他们喊出一个答案，而你弄不清楚为什么那是答案，你试了一下，它奏效了，然后让他们试着向你解释，你知道，谜题是怎么有那个答案的。他们不能，他们只是凭直觉，
but it happens way too much. And then you kind of feel bad and you're like trying to look at the hints to like understand why. Anyways, so Escape Simulator, definitely check it out. Works on macOS, Linux, at least in Steam Deck it worked and Windows.
但这发生得太频繁了。然后你有点感觉不好，你就像试图看提示来理解为什么。无论如何，所以《Escape Simulator》，一定要看看。可以在macOS、Linux上运行，至少在Steam Deck上它能运行，还有Windows。
Yeah, this looks super fun. I'm definitely gonna grab grab this is it like uh um like a split screen or is it internet co-op uh internet internet thing so yeah that's the only thing i couldn't figure out i just have one steam account i do have two computers but once you're playing on one steam library won't you play in another one so we just sort of sit together and like collaborate on one a one player game got it yeah that makes sense very funny could you also just buy it under two steam accounts and that would probably work fine you know there's a new thing not to digress too much
是的，这看起来超级有趣。我肯定会买，买这个，它是像，呃，嗯，像分屏还是互联网合作？互联网，互联网的东西，所以是的，这是我唯一弄不清楚的事情，我只有一个Steam账户，我确实有两台电脑，但一旦你在一个Steam库上玩，你就不能在另一个上玩，所以我们只是坐在一起，像在单人游戏中合作。明白了，是的，这说得通。很有趣，你也可以在两个Steam账户下买它，那可能工作得很好，你知道，有一个新东西，不要太离题
but steam has like a new feature now called family mode where um you can actually say like this computer is a family member and then what will happen is you can both play different games at the same time if you try to play the same game at the same time steam says hey uh you're gonna have to pay uh you know to buy a second copy but then when you do that that you can play together so like it kind of handles all of it this is good tips okay all right i'll be back in a few minutes all right my tool of the show is the cursor ide and you can go to cursor.com to grab this so this is basically uh github co-pilot and all of these things just on steroids at the next level. So when you start up Cursor, it asks if you want to import all of your VS Code extensions. So it's literally a fork of VS Code. I imported all my extensions.
但Steam现在有一个新功能叫家庭模式，嗯，你可以实际上说，这个电脑是一个家庭成员，然后会发生的是，你们俩可以同时玩不同的游戏。如果你试图同时玩同一个游戏，Steam说“嘿，呃，你得付钱，你知道，买第二份”，但当你这样做时，你们就可以一起玩了，所以它有点处理了所有这些。这是很好的建议。好的，好的，我几分钟后回来。好的，我的节目工具是Cursor IDE，你可以去cursor.com获取这个，所以这基本上是GitHub Copilot和所有这些东西，只是类固醇，在下一个水平。所以当你启动Cursor时，它会问你是否想导入你所有的VS Code扩展。所以它实际上是VS Code的一个分支。我导入了我所有的扩展。
They all imported just fine. The thing about Cursor that really blew my mind was it has like autocomplete that spans the entire file. So, for example, I had this app that was a WSGI app. It was basically a kind of a REST APIi app and i was converting it to flask and so one pattern that i had to go from is the old app you would return a json object and it would have a status key and then the http status code so like 200 if it was good 400 if it was now forward etc etc um and then and then your your payload and so most of the time in these little handlers i was returning an object where you know json object for like status 200 payload is data data was some object i created right
它们都导入得很好。关于Cursor真正让我震惊的事情是，它有跨越整个文件的自动完成。所以，例如，我有一个应用程序，是一个WSGI应用程序。它基本上是一种REST API应用程序，我正在把它转换为Flask，所以我必须遵循的一个模式是旧应用程序，你会返回一个JSON对象，它会有一个状态键，然后是HTTP状态码，比如200如果它是好的，400如果它是现在的，等等等等，嗯，然后，然后你的有效载荷，所以大多数时候在这些小处理程序中，我返回一个对象，你知道，JSON对象，比如状态200，有效载荷是数据，数据是我创建的某个对象，对吧
in flask you don't return anything from your handler, the handler gets past this response object, and you do response dot status 200. And then response dot data payload, right. And I changed it, there was there was a file that had a bunch of these handlers in it. So I changed it in one as i was changing it it let me tab complete to do that like it like like i was i was putting i put like response dot status like about halfway through the word status and it figured it out it's like what you want to do is sas 200 data payload and then delete the return thing and i hit tab that was cool then it like zipped down like a third of the way through the file and it's like you want to do it here too don't you hit tab and like i just hit tab tab tab tab tab and it just did all of it and that blew my freaking mind like i've used you know copilot and amazon q and stuff and they they they do like they do have some of those magical moments like within you know pretty close to where your cursor is but i've never seen it like this where it's like oh you also want to do this thing at this file over there
在Flask中，你不从处理程序返回任何东西，处理程序被传递这个响应对象，你做response.status 200。然后response.data有效载荷，对吧。我改变了它，有一个文件里有一堆这些处理程序。所以我改变了一个，当我改变它时，它让我按Tab键完成它，就像，就像我，我放了像response.status，在status这个词的一半左右，它弄清楚了，它就像“你想做的是status 200，数据有效载荷，然后删除返回的东西”，我按了Tab，那很酷，然后它像拉链一样向下，在文件的三分之一处，它就像“你也想在这里做，不是吗”，按Tab，就像我只是按Tab，Tab，Tab，Tab，Tab，它就完成了所有这些，这让我震惊了，就像我用过，你知道，Copilot和Amazon Q之类的，它们，它们确实，它们确实有一些那些神奇的时刻，就在，你知道，离你的光标很近的地方，但我从来没见过像这样，它就像“哦，你也想在那个文件里做这件事”
uh it just like it just like kept chaining these things to do and uh um and he got it all perfect like you know there was weirdness around the brackets and all of that you know is is kind of complicated because i was adding this handler and so it's actually adding a bracket but then deleting the return bracket and it like figured it all out flawlessly um uh it was really impressive um again i think we've talked about this in the past if you're at a company make sure you get the right approval we were just talking about junior engineers we don't want you to get fired if you're a junior engineer and you get fired that will make us sad get the right approval but this is an amazing tool that's very cool is it in the works for it to be able to do it across files in your project as well like if you wanted to refactor all of your files to you know use flask or whatever
呃，它就像，它就像一直链接这些事情来做，而且，嗯，他把它全部弄得完美，就像，你知道，括号周围有奇怪的地方，所有这些，你知道，有点复杂，因为我正在添加这个处理程序，所以它实际上是在添加一个括号，但随后删除了返回括号，它就像完美地弄清楚了所有事情，嗯，呃，这真的很令人印象深刻，嗯，再次，我想我们过去谈过这个，如果你在一家公司，确保你得到正确的批准，我们刚才在谈论初级工程师，我们不想让你被解雇，如果你是一个初级工程师，你被解雇了，那会让我们难过，得到正确的批准，但这是一款很棒的工具，这非常酷。它是否正在开发中，以便它也能在你的项目中跨文件执行此操作？比如如果你想重构你所有的文件以，你知道，使用Flask或别的什么
like is there a way to like invoke it to do that or not yet i don't think so i'm trying to remember uh it definitely jumps around in the same file. I don't think it has a way to skip other files yet, but it might. I've just started using it a few days ago. Okay. And what is the zip down? So like it zips down and then like,
比如有没有办法调用它来做这件事，还是还没有？我不这么认为，我正在努力回忆，呃，它绝对会在同一个文件中跳来跳去。我不认为它有办法跳过其他文件，但它可能有。我只是几天前才开始使用它。好的。那么什么是拉链向下？所以就像，它拉链向下，然后就像，
if you don't want to do it, it just returns you back to where you are. I feel like I'll get a whiplash. Oh, interesting. That's a good point. You know uh yeah i guess i'm not totally sure so the times where it did this i took it took their suggestion every time i think maybe if you don't take the suggestion maybe you could hit the up arrow on the key and get teleported back i sent a new developer metric which is how often do you accept the ai suggestion oh definitely yeah i'm sure if they're not measuring that they should be and yeah i guess you're right they should pass that measurement along to the company no i'm saying you're like
如果你不想做，它只是把你带回你所在的地方。我觉得我会得鞭打。哦，有趣。那是个好点。你知道，呃，是的，我想我不完全确定，所以它做这件事的时候，我每次都接受了他们的建议，我想也许如果你不接受建议，你可以按键上的向上箭头，被传送回去。我发送了一个新的开发者指标，就是你多久接受一次AI建议。哦，绝对是的，我肯定如果他们没有测量那个，他们应该测量，而且是的，我想你是对的，他们应该把那个测量结果传达给公司。不，我说的是你就像
as an engineer you get a score which is like the more you accept the ai thing the like worse off you're not adding anything they could just replace you with the ai so you need to like then there's this whole gamesmanship right because then we'll figure it out and we'll just write what the ai said but change one character so it doesn't count and then our metric for you know novelness goes up yeah well you know it's interesting i mean i think that um yeah i mean you know the next level up from this would be for me to say you know convert this kind of like raw lambda handler into flask and it would have just figured out because the thing that i had to provide was the knowledge that when you return things flask doesn't care like it's it's it's not going
作为一个工程师，你得到一个分数，就是你越接受AI的东西，就越糟糕，你没有添加任何东西，他们可以用AI取代你，所以你需要像，然后有这种整个博弈论，对吧，因为然后我们会弄清楚，我们只会写AI说的东西，但改变一个字符，这样它就不算数了，然后我们对，你知道，新颖性的指标就会上升。是的，好吧，你知道，这很有趣，我的意思是，我认为，嗯，是的，我的意思是，你知道，从这个水平上升一级，对我来说就是说，你知道，把这种原始的Lambda处理程序转换成Flask，它就会弄清楚，因为我必须提供的东西是知识，即当你返回东西时，Flask不在乎，就像它，它不会
to use that return value and so like just like running this code on flask means that you would just error 500 everything right and so like i had to figure that out and then once i started typing the solution then it was done um but yeah i mean at some point maybe it will that's that's almost like a segue uh or another thing is you know junior engineers now also have to compete with ai uh or or maybe maybe not maybe it makes them on a more level playing field. That's still kind of an unknown. I don't, yeah, I don't have a, I think this is a watch this space. No, no, that's not how they say that. This is like a watch the future.
使用那个返回值，所以就像在Flask上运行这段代码意味着你只会让一切错误500，对吧，所以我必须弄清楚这一点，然后一旦我开始输入解决方案，它就完成了，但是的，我的意思是，在某个时候也许它会，那几乎就像一个过渡，或者另一件事是，你知道，初级工程师现在也必须与AI竞争，或者，或者也许，也许不，也许它让他们处于一个更公平的竞争环境。这仍然是一个未知数。我不，是的，我没有，我认为这是一个“关注这个空间”。不，不，他们不是那样说的。这就像一个“关注未来”。
I don't know what will happen. I think where I'm sitting now, but this has turned out to be wrong before, but like you said, it's sort of the intent still needs to be provided and and sort of guided but people who lean in on it probably see a big improvement before everyone else and then everyone else sort of adapts or not and it we call it the same thing but it's not really the same thing so you know it's like programming a website is technically programming and programming an operating system is also
我不知道会发生什么。我认为我现在的处境，但这之前被证明是错误的，但就像你说的，它仍然需要提供意图，并进行某种引导，但那些倾向于它的人可能比其他人更早看到巨大的改进，然后其他人会适应或不适应，我们称之为同样的事情，但它并不是真正同样的事情，所以你知道，这就像编程一个网站在技术上是编程，编程一个操作系统也是
technically programming uh they're not really the same thing like some parts are similar but lots of parts are different i think we'll just end up with more divergence so there's some things you're doing like you're saying hey i'm looking for another web framework that may be faster and it suggests to you to go to you know whatever um but then there's also times where you might just be straight up like this is something that's not been done before and it needs to be written for the first time yeah yeah that makes sense. It's going to be a wild time. I think these tools will save people a lot of busy work, which is good. But it also means that you will have to memorize the code base faster
技术上是编程，它们并不是真正同样的事情，就像有些部分是相似的，但很多部分是不同的，我认为我们最终会得到更多的分歧，所以有些事情你在做，就像你在说“嘿，我正在寻找另一个可能更快的Web框架”，它建议你去，你知道，别的什么，但也有时候你可能只是直接说“这是以前没做过的事情，它需要第一次被写出来”。是的，是的，这说得通。这将是一个疯狂的时代。我认为这些工具会为人们节省很多忙碌的工作，这很好。但也意味着你将不得不更快地记住代码库
because you're not going to be sitting there staring at it while you do busy work. All right, on to the topic of the show vector databases so patrick have you ever used a vector database no all right but you have used a database yes um do you uh have you ever put uh like anything other than text in a database you know like have you ever used a database for images or yes what did you use for that do you just stuff an image into my sql or what protobuf oh you put protobufs in the database oh yeah really so but that's just like garbage, right? Like, you know, it's unintelligible. Wow, bro. You're coming at me.
因为你不会在做忙碌工作时盯着它看。好的，关于节目主题向量数据库，所以帕特里克，你用过向量数据库吗？不，好的，但你用过数据库，是的，你有没有在数据库中放入除文本以外的任何东西，你知道，比如你有没有把数据库用于图像，或者是的，你用什么来做那个？你只是把图像塞进MySQL还是什么？Protobuf，哦，你把Protobuf放进数据库，哦，是的，真的吗？所以但这只是垃圾，对吧？就像，你知道，它是不可理解的。哇，兄弟。你在针对我。
No, no, no, no. I don't mean it's garbage quality. I mean, when you look, when you run a query, it's unintelligible. Yeah, you can't index it sort of properly. Yeah, you're right. Yeah, because like when you query, I think if you certain databases they let you have like a column be a jpeg and the database kind of knows it's a jpeg and so when you query it it will actually show you pictures oh that's cool can you query oh no no it's not i was gonna say could you
不，不，不，不。我不是说它是垃圾质量。我的意思是，当你查看时，当你运行查询时，它是不可理解的。是的，你不能正确地索引它。是的，你是对的。是的，因为就像当你查询时，我想如果你某些数据库，它们让你有一列是JPEG，数据库有点知道它是JPEG，所以当你查询它时，它实际上会向你展示图片。哦，那很酷，你能查询吗？哦，不，不，我本来要说你能
query stuff about it like i'm looking for jpegs where the subject is read uh you could with a vector database oh okay here we go i'm ready i'm here i'm leaning in all right um so yeah my mind is still is still blown by the so okay hang on i gotta dive in a little bit so if you put a protobuf in a database right yeah then i guess most languages have protobuf support but you would have to like you know you know uh interpret that protobuf before you do anything with that data so like you know your your sql query goes straight to something that like converts the protobuf to like yeah i mean you can use just more like a key value store where the value rather than a relational database right so it becomes more like hey i mean you can use just more like a key value store where the value rather than a
查询关于它的东西吗，比如我正在寻找主题是红色的JPEG，你可以用向量数据库。哦，好的，我们开始吧，我准备好了，我在这里，我正在倾听。好的，嗯，所以是的，我的大脑仍然，仍然被，所以好的，等一下，我得深入一点，所以如果你把Protobuf放进数据库，对吧，是的，那么我想大多数语言都有Protobuf支持，但你必须像，你知道，你，你知道，呃，在对该数据做任何事情之前解释那个Protobuf，所以就像，你知道，你的SQL查询直接指向某种将Protobuf转换为，就像，是的，我的意思是，你可以使用更多像键值存储的东西，其中值而不是关系数据库，对吧，所以它变得更像，嘿，我的意思是，你可以使用更多像键值存储的东西，其中值而不是
relational database right so it becomes more like hey i have these keys and then just have the lobs got it okay cool uh okay so let's build a scaffold up to vector databases so um okay people like starting from the beginning, how do computers represent things? So, for example, you open up Notepad, you start typing some letters in Notepad, you hit save, and it saves as a text file. And so, not dealing with Unicode or anything like that, just putting that aside. A text file is basically a bunch of bytes where, you know, each byte represents one letter. So, the letter, there's an ascii table you can look up and so i don't remember off top of my head i think isn't like 97 a lowercase a or something it's been a long time but uh but but you know each letter and each symbol you know
关系数据库，对吧，所以它变得更像，嘿，我有这些键，然后只是有LOB，明白了，好的，酷，呃，好的，让我们建立一个通向向量数据库的脚手架，所以，嗯，好的，人们喜欢从头开始，计算机是如何表示事物的？所以，例如，你打开记事本，你开始在记事本中输入一些字母，你点击保存，它保存为文本文件。所以，不处理Unicode之类的东西，只是把那个放在一边。文本文件基本上是一堆字节，其中，你知道，每个字节代表一个字母。所以，字母，有一个ASCII表你可以查阅，所以我记不清了，我想97是不是小写a之类的，已经很久了，但呃，但但你知道每个字母和每个符号，你知道
equal sign apostrophe they all map to numbers and in at least the ascii format there's less than 256 of these uh or uh different things and so that's one byte in a computer and so your document is you know a byte for each of these letters including the spaces and all of that um so that's how you know traditionally how you could represent text in a computer so a computer obviously doesn't have a concept really of the letter a you know in hardware um that's the way it works um and for images the same kind of thing you know there isn't like any lithography uh is that the right word? But, you know, there's no like dark room in your computer. Like there's no physical images in your computer. The way it works is, you know, each picture is broken up into pixels, which is like a really tiny square of an image, hopefully so tiny you can't even tell it's a square and then for each pixel the color
等号，撇号，它们都映射到数字，并且至少在ASCII格式中，这些少于256个，或者，呃，不同的东西，所以那是计算机中的一个字节，所以你的文档是，你知道，这些字母中的每一个的一个字节，包括空格和所有这些，嗯，所以这就是，你知道，传统上你如何在计算机中表示文本，所以计算机显然没有真正对字母a的概念，你知道，在硬件中，那是它的工作方式，嗯，对于图像也是同样的事情，你知道，没有像任何光刻，那是正确的词吗？但是，你知道，你的计算机里没有暗室。就像你的计算机里没有物理图像。它的工作方式是，你知道，每张图片被分解成像素，这就像图像的一个非常小的正方形，希望小到你甚至看不出它是一个正方形，然后对于每个像素，颜色
could be represented as you know the amount of our red green and blue representation in that pixel and so you can imagine um you know if you have a picture a bunch of these triples your red green blue triples and you have one for every pixel um and you know the width and the height of the image so you know like what that whole rectangle looks like and that's how pictures are represented in the computer um does that make sense anything you want to add to that patrick yeah i mean i think you're right i think what you're trying to point out is the computer doesn't have a native understanding of most of these concepts so it just has operation bytes and like data bytes and the data bytes need a an encoding they need a scheme and the humans are the
可以表示为，你知道，那个像素中红色、绿色和蓝色表示的数量，所以你可以想象，嗯，你知道，如果你有一张图片，一堆这些三元组，你的红绿蓝三元组，你为每个像素有一个，嗯，你知道图像的宽度和高度，所以你知道，你知道整个矩形看起来像什么，这就是图片在计算机中表示的方式，嗯，这说得通吗？有什么你想补充的吗，帕特里克？是的，我的意思是，我想你是对的，我想你试图指出的是，计算机对大多数这些概念没有原生的理解，所以它只有操作字节和像数据字节，数据字节需要一种编码，它们需要一种方案，而人类是
one that imbue meaning to those yeah that makes sense so um okay so then we'll get into like let's say compression so for example you know you might have a document that has the same word a bunch of times it's like chapter one chapter two chapter three and so every time you have the word chapter that's going to be uh what seven bytes right to store all of those characters um but if it's always like chapter chapter chapter section section section there's like a lot of repetition there and so you could actually have a smaller file by taking advantage of all of this repetition and so one example that most people are taught in undergrad and I've long since forgotten is Huffman encoding.
赋予这些意义的人。是的，这说得通。所以，嗯，好的，那么我们将进入像压缩之类的，所以例如，你知道，你可能有一个文档，里面有很多次同样的单词，就像第一章，第二章，第三章，所以每次你有“章”这个词，那将是，呃，七个字节，对吧，来存储所有这些字符，但如果它总是像“章，章，章，节，节，节”，那里有很多重复，所以你实际上可以通过利用所有这些重复来拥有一个更小的文件，所以一个大多数人在本科阶段被教导，而我早已忘记的例子是Huffman编码。
I don't, do you remember Huffman coding? Yes, yeah. It's something to do with like trees, right? Like you build a tree where- And the prefixes. Yeah, maybe you explain it, because I've totally- No, no, no, no, that was good.
我不知道，你记得Huffman编码吗？是的，是的。它和树之类的东西有关，对吧？就像你建立一棵树，其中——还有前缀。是的，也许你解释一下，因为我完全——不，不，不，不，那很好。
Yeah, yeah. So you like look in your file and you have to look at the whole file at once and basically decide like how am i going to assign bits to the most common prefixes of numbers and each branch of the tree represents sort of like going down that way and so it can represent a bucket of the prefixes that get concatenated together and ultimately that way most the most common pieces use the fewest bits and then the longer deeper parts of the tree encode the the less common pieces yep that makes sense and so um and so you could do something similar for images right you could have some kind of delta
是的，是的。所以你就像在你的文件中查看，你必须一次查看整个文件，并基本上决定，就像我将如何为数字的最常见前缀分配位，树的每个分支代表某种向下走的方式，所以它可以表示连接在一起的前缀桶，最终那样，最常见的片段使用最少的位，然后树的更深、更长的部分编码不太常见的片段。是的，这说得通，所以，嗯，所以你可以对图像做类似的事情，对吧，你可以有某种增量
encoding or other kind of things that take advantage of the nature of the image. But you know, for images, really, you know, you want to capture the sort of nature of the image, right? So it might not matter that like this single pixel in this one part of the car is like a little bit more blue in the image than it was in real life like it doesn't that doesn't really change the nature of the image and so now you start getting into what are called lossy compressions or lossy encodings so for example one of the most common uh is where you take these um uh various kind of repeating patterns so such as like a fourier cycles or cosine cycles you know the cosine wave right you take these kind of waves
编码或其他种类的东西，利用图像的性质。但是，你知道，对于图像，真的，你知道，你想要捕捉图像的某种性质，对吧？所以这可能并不重要，就像汽车这一部分的这个单个像素在图像中比在现实中稍微蓝一点，就像它，那并没有真正改变图像的性质，所以现在你开始进入所谓的有损压缩或有损编码，所以例如，最常见的呃之一是，你采取这些，嗯，呃，各种重复模式，比如像傅里叶循环或余弦循环，你知道余弦波，对吧，你采取这些种类的波
and you compose them at different frequencies and amplitudes on top of each other so um um so for example uh if you imagine like a zebra so zebra is this like really sharp kind of wave where it's it's white and then it's black and it's white and it's black and so if the camera zooms in on the zebra now the sort of frequency is getting smaller right because those stripes are getting bigger the camera zooms out or the zebra's running away or something now the frequency starts going up and so what you do is you you you have a ton of different uh waves of different frequencies and you have there's an algorithm that tries to figure out how you can compose like add many of these waves together to faithfully
然后你将它们以不同的频率和振幅叠加在一起，所以，嗯，举个例子，如果你想象一只斑马，斑马身上的条纹是一种非常清晰的波，它是白色的，然后是黑色的，又是白色的，又是黑色的。所以如果摄像机放大斑马，频率就会变小，对吧？因为那些条纹变大了。如果摄像机拉远，或者斑马跑远了之类的，频率就开始升高。所以你要做的是，你拥有大量不同频率的波，并且有一个算法试图找出如何将这些波组合起来，也就是将许多这样的波加在一起，从而忠实地
reconstruct the image and if you can do that then you only need to store like the definitions of those waves like what were the amplitudes and the frequencies of those waves um instead of storing every single pixel i mean i think just to completeness there you need infinitely many but if you have some lost criteria like some amount of thing you're willing to give up, then you can basically chop and only take the top X most important frequencies. And then you'll get back most of the image. Yeah, yeah, exactly. That's a really good segue to the next part.
重建图像。如果你能做到这一点，那么你只需要存储这些波的定义，比如这些波的振幅和频率是多少，而不是存储每一个像素。我的意思是，为了完整起见，你需要无限多的波，但如果你有一些损失标准，比如你愿意放弃一定量的信息，那么你基本上可以进行裁剪，只取最重要的前 X 个频率。然后你就能还原大部分图像了。是的，是的，完全正确。这是一个很好的过渡，引出下一部分。
So now we'll jump into embed embeddings right so um we talked about ways to kind of explicitly represent something so if you have a document and you want to store it you explicitly represent you each individual character um but many times what we want is to know like the overall essence of a document, like, is this document about cars? Uh, or is this a long document or does this, is this document at a really high reading level or at a kindergarten reading level? So these sort of like soft attributes, uh, those sound like kind of yes, no questions. But really, there's a lot of ambiguity there, right?
现在我们来谈谈嵌入（embeddings），对吧？所以，我们讨论了显式表示某事物的方法。如果你有一个文档，想要存储它，你会显式地表示每一个字符。但很多时候，我们想要知道的是文档的整体精髓，比如，这个文档是关于汽车的吗？或者这是一个长文档？或者这个文档的阅读水平很高，还是处于幼儿园水平？所以这些所谓的“软属性”，听起来像是那种“是”或“否”的问题。但实际上，这里面有很多模糊性，对吧？
It's like there's certain degrees of like, how much about cars is this or, or how much of this document is at the kindergarten reading level. So, so, you know, these kind of like soft attributes. And then doing things like give me all the documents that are roughly a yes for this question. So it's kind of like a lossy attribute system. And the best way that we have today to be able to answer questions like that is through embeddings.
就像存在某种程度的问题，比如“这篇文档有多少内容是关于汽车的”或者“这篇文档有多少内容处于幼儿园阅读水平”。所以，你知道，这些就是所谓的“软属性”。然后做一些事情，比如“给我所有对这个问题大致回答为‘是’的文档”。所以这有点像是一个有损属性系统。而我们今天能够回答这类问题的最好方法就是通过嵌入。
So the goal of an embedding, it's not directly to recover the original document, as we talked about before. So you know, with Huffman encoding, the goal is to compress something so that you can later decompress not to get back the original thing the goal is to be able to answer questions around nearness you know if i have a query or or or a you know a concept or the query might even be another document right what are the things near that query um semantic nearness that's the goal and so because of that embeddings can be you know very very lossy because they don't really have to reconstruct the original content and so there's there's two kind of key ways that embeddings are created so one way is through contrastive methods so the idea here is i might say, these two documents were written by
所以嵌入的目标并不是直接恢复原始文档，正如我们之前讨论的那样。你知道，对于霍夫曼编码，目标是压缩某物以便稍后解压，而不是为了找回原始事物。嵌入的目标是能够回答关于“邻近性”的问题。你知道，如果我有一个查询，或者一个概念，甚至查询本身可能是另一个文档，那么哪些东西与该查询接近呢？语义上的邻近性，这就是目标。正因为如此，嵌入可以是，你知道，非常非常有损的，因为它们并不真正需要重建原始内容。所以，创建嵌入主要有两种关键方法：一种是通过对比学习方法。这里的想法是，我可能会说，这两个文档是由
kindergartners. So I know I'm going to be asking a lot of questions about reading level and reading skill for these documents. So I have documents created by kindergartners, I have documents created by adults, and I randomly pick two documents. If they were both created by the same age group, then I want their embeddings to be closer together. If they were created by a mix of a kindergartner and an adult, if one document was a kindergartner and the other document was an adult then i want to pull those two documents apart in this space and so uh and so at the very beginning of your embedding process all the documents are just randomly projected and so they're just scattered all over the place but after you ask yourself and answer this question many, many, many times,
幼儿园小朋友写的。所以我知道我以后会问很多关于这些文档的阅读水平和阅读能力的问题。所以我有一些由幼儿园小朋友创建的文档，也有由成年人创建的文档，然后我随机挑选两个文档。如果它们都是由同一个年龄段的人创建的，那么我希望它们的嵌入在空间中更接近。如果它们是由幼儿园小朋友和成年人的文档混合而成的，如果一个文档是幼儿园小朋友写的，另一个是成年人写的，那么我希望在空间中将这两个文档拉开。所以，在嵌入过程的最初，所有文档只是被随机投影，所以它们只是散落在各处。但在你问自己并回答这个问题很多、很多、很多次之后，
you end up with hopefully, you'll end up with sort of two, you'll end up with many spaces, many clusters. But each of those clusters will be either a kindergartner document cluster, or a grown up document cluster because of all of this pulling and pushing. Does that make sense? Yeah, I mean, I think the pulling and pushing... Now, does that happen in a subset of the dimensions, or are they guaranteed that even in another dimension, they may be far apart? Yeah, so when you pull or push, you do it in all the dimensions. So it's almost like there's little
你最终会得到，希望如此，你会得到两个，你会得到许多空间，许多聚类。但由于所有的拉近和推开操作，每一个聚类要么是幼儿园小朋友的文档聚类，要么是成年人的文档聚类。这有意义吗？是的，我的意思是，我认为这种拉近和推开……那么，这是发生在维度的一个子集中吗？还是说它们能保证即使在另一个维度上，它们也可能相距甚远？是的，所以当你拉近或推开时，你是在所有维度上进行的。所以这几乎就像是有小
thrusters on these two documents, there are points in embedded space, and those thrusters are pulling them together in every dimension simultaneously, or pushing them apart. And so when you do this embedding, you know, a single dimension has no real meaning because the only meaning was constructed from the distances, the pairwise distances. So you can't say dimension three is how many times they said the word dog or something because it's all like a composition of all these dimensions. So you need all of the things you're trying to do this
推进器在这些文档上，它们是嵌入空间中的点，这些推进器在所有维度上同时将它们拉在一起，或者将它们推开。所以当你做这种嵌入时，你知道，单个维度没有真正的意义，因为唯一的意义是根据距离，即成对距离构建出来的。所以你不能说第三个维度是他们说了多少次“狗”这个词之类的，因为它是由所有这些维度的组合构成的。所以你需要所有你试图用它来做的事情
with up front though um you need uh okay so when you're when you're training you provide a bunch of training examples and those have to be labeled right so you have to know this is kindergarteners adult um once you've trained the model then you can give it new documents. And you could even ask it like, is this new document a kindergartner or an adult document? And then it would use a vector database to look at like, what are the nearest neighbors?
提前准备好。嗯，你需要……好的，所以当你训练时，你提供一堆训练样本，这些样本必须被标记，对吧？所以你必须知道这是幼儿园小朋友写的，这是成年人写的。一旦你训练好了模型，你就可以给它新的文档。你甚至可以问它，比如，“这个新文档是幼儿园小朋友写的还是成年人写的？”然后它会使用向量数据库来查看，什么是最近的邻居？
And if most of those are kid documents, then that's one way that you can answer that question. Got it. So that's one way that you can answer that question got it um so so that's one way you give it a bunch of pairs um of things that you know are are you know should be close together or should be far apart um there's another way to do it where it's kind of like a fill in the blank right so for example um you might here's an example let's say i have three documents written by a kindergartner and i give a model the first one and i give a model the third one and then i say hey generate the second one um maybe maybe you ask a kindergartner you know
如果其中大多数是儿童文档，那么这就是回答该问题的一种方式。明白了。所以这是回答该问题的一种方式，明白了。所以，这是一种方式，你给它一堆你知道应该靠得很近或应该离得很远的事物对。还有另一种方法，它有点像“填空”，对吧？例如，你可能会……这是一个例子，假设我有三篇由幼儿园小朋友写的文档，我给模型第一篇，给模型第三篇，然后我说，“嘿，生成第二篇”。也许，也许你问一个幼儿园小朋友，你知道，
write a book about dogs write a book about goldfish write a book about cars and you present the ai that you're training you know two of three books, and you say generate the third one. And in the beginning,ner and you go to the ai and say hey you were wrong like here's the actual answer um and they do the same thing with like adult books right and and it turns out that like if all you're doing is kind of filling in the middle whether it's the middle of a sentence the middle of a collection of work or whatever it is because you're just filling out the middle and you already have the middle like you know the right answer you don't actually need any humans in the loop so like i could just take all of wikipedia and i could give every sentence to some ai that i'm
“写一本关于狗的书，写一本关于金鱼的书，写一本关于汽车的书”，然后你把你正在训练的 AI 展示（你知道，三本书中的两本），然后你说“生成第三本”。起初，你去找 AI 说，“嘿，你错了，这是实际的答案”。他们对成人书籍也做同样的事情，对吧？结果发现，如果你所做的只是填补中间部分，无论是句子的中间、作品集的中间还是其他什么，因为你只是在填补中间，而且你已经有了中间部分，你知道正确答案，所以你实际上不需要任何人在循环中。所以我可以只拿走所有的维基百科，我可以把每一句话给某个我正在
training and say like hey like fill in the beginning of the sentence or the end of the sentence or the middle and and I know the right answer. And so when it doesn't give me the right answer, I kind of push it, give the right answer. And so this is called self-supervised models. if if i give it the end of something and tell it to reconstruct the beginning then when i actually try to use this model in real life i have to give it the end of something but if i'm using this to do like chat gbt i can't do that like you can't say all right you're given the end of what chat gbt wants to say, give me the beginning. It doesn't work that way. And so usually you have to, you're forced to go in the other direction. So you're
训练的 AI，然后说，“嘿，填补句子的开头、结尾或中间”，我知道正确答案。所以当它没有给我正确答案时，我就会推动它，给出正确答案。这就是所谓的自监督模型。如果我给它某物的结尾并告诉它重建开头，那么当我真正尝试在现实生活中使用这个模型时，我必须给它某物的结尾。但如果我用它来做像 ChatGPT 这样的东西，我就不能那样做。你不能说，“好吧，给你 ChatGPT 想说的结尾，给我开头。”它不是那样工作的。所以通常你被迫朝另一个方向走。所以你
like, you know, you purposely hide the ending completely. You artificially hide the middle and you give the beginning. When the model tells you the middle, you correct the model. And so because you're never able to look at the future, these are called forward models, because they can only take the past and predict the future. And so GPT is an example without the chat part is an example of just a pure forward model. So, you know, given like a bunch of things you said, this is your context, what's the next thing that that's going to be said, and it's trained on, you know, terabytes and terabytes of text. And then now it generates that token. But along the way of generating that token, it constructs an embedding. So it constructs an embedding first, and then it uses that embedding to predict the next token. And so if you're not interested or not, you don't need that second part, you can just take the first part.
就像，你知道，你故意完全隐藏结尾。你人为地隐藏中间部分，然后给出开头。当模型告诉你中间部分时，你纠正模型。因为你永远无法看到未来，这些被称为前向模型，因为它们只能获取过去并预测未来。所以 GPT（不带聊天部分）就是一个纯粹的前向模型的例子。所以，你知道，给定你所说的一堆东西，这是你的上下文，接下来要说的是什么？它是在，你知道，数 TB 的文本上训练的。然后现在它生成那个标记。但在生成该标记的过程中，它构建了一个嵌入。所以它先构建一个嵌入，然后使用该嵌入来预测下一个标记。所以如果你不感兴趣，或者你不需要第二部分，你可以只取第一部分。
And now you have an embedding of the words that have been said so far. And so this is why as like a byproduct of making these chatbots, the companies can also offer an embedding service is because they need that internally. So you can offer it externally. And it's valuable for the reasons you're describing, is now if i have text maybe it's not a chat it's just i have text and i want a representation of it that i can ask questions about then i can get the embedding and then do whatever i want with it yep yeah exactly right. And there are vision transformers that work very similarly where you take a picture, you hide part of the picture from the AI, and you ask the AI to recreate that part of the picture. When it does, you have the real answer because you are the one who hid it yourself.
现在你就有了到目前为止所说单词的嵌入。这就是为什么作为制作这些聊天机器人的副产品，公司也可以提供嵌入服务，因为他们在内部需要它。所以你可以对外提供它。这对于你所描述的原因很有价值，现在如果我有文本，也许它不是聊天，只是我有文本，我想要一个我可以对其提问的表示，那么我可以获得嵌入，然后随心所欲地使用它。是的，完全正确。还有视觉转换器（vision transformers），它们的工作方式非常相似，你拿一张图片，向 AI 隐藏图片的一部分，然后要求 AI 重建那部分图片。当它这样做时，你就有了真正的答案，因为是你自己隐藏了它。
And you compare the AI generation with the reality and you correct the AI. And similar to language, a vision transformer, you know, has a step where there is an embedding representation. So you can take a picture and run like half of the vision transformer and now you just have this embedding where the picture is going to be car and asked the AI to redraw the car, all those pictures are going to have very similar embeddings. But the picture where like you deleted a person from who is in the background of your family portrait, and you wanted the AI to like fill that in with something.
然后你将 AI 的生成与现实进行比较，并纠正 AI。与语言类似，视觉转换器，你知道，有一个步骤是存在嵌入表示的。所以你可以拿一张图片并运行一半的视觉转换器，现在你就有了这个嵌入，图片将是汽车，并要求 AI 重绘汽车，所有这些图片都将有非常相似的嵌入。但是，如果你从家庭肖像的背景中删除了一个人，并且你希望 AI 填补那个位置，
All those pictures will occupy like a different space in the embedding um so um yeah i mean this is you know this gets pretty kind of difficult to explain over over the air but any questions about that part of it no i i mean i think it makes sense so the idea is you're getting a vector which i guess we talk about like it's a list of numbers and those numbers represent like where in this space it is and the hope is that for these processes that you learn the ways in which things can be similar or different right right and so um okay so now let's talk about how to correct the ai so let's say you let's say the sentence was you know the quick brown fox jumps over the lazy what is it lazy
所有这些图片将在嵌入中占据不同的空间。所以，嗯，是的，我的意思是，这在广播中很难解释，但关于那部分有什么问题吗？没有，我的意思是，我认为这很有道理。所以想法是你得到一个向量，我想我们谈论它就像它是一个数字列表，这些数字代表它在这个空间中的位置。希望对于这些过程，你能学习到事物可以相似或不同的方式，对吧？对，所以，好的，现在让我们谈谈如何纠正 AI。假设你……假设句子是，你知道，“The quick brown fox jumps over the lazy”，是什么？lazy
dog or something yes yeah so let's say the ai generates the brown fox jumps over the lazy dog so got everything right except for the word quick right but because it skipped the word quick every word after that is kind of wrong right it's like shifted right so you have to develop all sorts of different uh metrics to be able able to say how wrong the AI was in a way that helps it learn well. That's at the training side. It turns out the embeddings, you're often trying to use embeddings for a different purpose. For example, you might want to fill in the missing image, the missing part of the image when you're training. But then when you're actually using the
dog 之类的。是的，是的。所以假设 AI 生成了“the brown fox jumps over the lazy dog”。所以除了“quick”这个词之外，其他都对了。但因为它跳过了“quick”这个词，后面的每一个词都有点错了，对吧？就像向右偏移了。所以你必须开发各种不同的指标，以便能够说出 AI 错得有多离谱，从而帮助它学好。那是在训练端。事实证明，嵌入，你通常试图将嵌入用于不同的目的。例如，你可能想在训练时填补缺失的图像，缺失的图像部分。但当你真正使用
model, you want to group all of your images together. So someone can say, hey, this is a picture of me at the beach, find more like this one, which is different than when you're training it so we call this training serving skew it's when you use a model for a different use than it's it's uh what it was trained how it was trained um and so what that means is the similarity metric on the embedding like there's a lot of unknowns there like you know like it might be that the model was just trained to fill in parts of the image and so it actually does a terrible job of of finding similar images it might just be a coincidence right that it does a good job right so so there's not a lot of theory at this point and when there's not a lot theory, the best thing you can do is try a lot of things. And so, you want to have a variety of different similarity metrics on the embeddings.
模型时，你想要将所有的图像分组在一起。所以有人可以说，“嘿，这是我在海滩上的照片，找到更多像这样的照片”，这与你训练它时不同。所以我们称之为“训练服务偏差”（training serving skew），即当你将模型用于与训练方式不同的用途时。所以这意味着嵌入上的相似性度量，那里有很多未知数。比如，模型可能只是为了填补图像部分而训练的，所以它在寻找相似图像方面实际上做得非常糟糕。这可能只是一个巧合，对吧？它做得好可能只是巧合。所以目前还没有太多的理论。当没有太多理论时，你能做的最好的事情就是尝试很多事情。所以，你想要在嵌入上有各种不同的相似性度量。
So, a common one is just how close something is like in Euclidean space. But then there are a bunch of others too. We don't need to dive into all of them, but there's a ton of different similarity metrics. And so, you know, once you've chosen a similarity metric, then you can say, given a point in this space where the point can have a document on it or not, find the nearest neighbors, find the nearest documents to that point um and uh um and then you can look at those results and see okay does that match what i was hoping from a product perspective so the point that you're making and getting neighbors like a query but the query is not uh doesn't have to be a text like you said could be a picture it could be whatever it gets the embedding and then the goal well maybe
所以，一个常见的度量就是某物在欧几里得空间中有多近。但还有很多其他的。我们不需要深入探讨所有这些，但有大量的不同相似性度量。所以，你知道，一旦你选择了一个相似性度量，那么你就可以说，给定这个空间中的一个点（该点上可能有文档，也可能没有），找到最近的邻居，找到离该点最近的文档。然后你可以查看这些结果，看看“好的，这是否符合我从产品角度所期望的？”所以你提出的观点和获取邻居就像一个查询，但查询不一定是文本，就像你说的，它可以是图片，它可以是任何东西。它获取嵌入，然后目标……好吧，也许
i'm jumping jumping the gun here but the goal of the vector database is to help you efficiently find the things closest to your query yeah yeah exactly right yeah so um just like we talked about with the fourier transform as pat Patrick said you know you'd need an infinite number of waves to get you know a perfect resolution but you're often willing to tolerate you know error um similarly you know if you're willing to tolerate error in finding out which documents are the closest then you can do what's called sublinear approximate nearest neighbors so the idea is if i have a million documents i don't need to check the embedding of all million of them to get the nearest neighbors to a point. I can use a variety of different data structures to say, okay, I'm extremely confident that I have the nearest neighbors, but I'm not 100% confident.
我操之过急了，但向量数据库的目标是帮助你有效地找到最接近你查询的事物。是的，完全正确。所以，就像我们谈论傅里叶变换时 Patrick 所说的那样，你知道，你需要无限数量的波才能获得完美的分辨率，但你通常愿意容忍误差。同样地，如果你愿意容忍在找出哪些文档最接近时的误差，那么你可以做所谓的“次线性近似最近邻”（sublinear approximate nearest neighbors）。所以想法是，如果我有一百万个文档，我不需要检查所有一百万个文档的嵌入来获得某一点的最近邻居。我可以使用各种不同的数据结构来说，“好的，我非常确信我拥有最近的邻居，但我不是 100% 确信。”
So for example, maybe there's a partitioning system. And if you fall like exactly just to the left or right of a partition boundary you might miss what's on the other side of the partition um and that might happen one out of every 10 million times and only affect one result and so you're you're more than happy taking that penalty in exchange for just massive massive speed up so imagine like uh we're talking like going from like a million seconds to search to six you know or something like that so um so that's basically what the vector database does so the vector database has it so where you provide your own embeddings it doesn't do that part but you jam a bunch of embeddings into this
所以例如，也许有一个分区系统。如果你正好落在分区边界的左侧或右侧，你可能会错过分区另一侧的内容。这种情况可能每 1000 万次发生一次，并且只影响一个结果。所以你非常乐意接受这种惩罚，以换取巨大的速度提升。所以想象一下，我们谈论的是从一百万秒的搜索变成六秒，或者类似的东西。所以，这基本上就是向量数据库所做的。所以向量数据库有它，你提供你自己的嵌入，它不做那部分，但你把一堆嵌入塞进这个
vector database, it creates all of these data structures, and then you can give it vector queries, and it will tell you the nearest neighbors. And the vector database is responsible for managing sort of the dynamics there. So for for example if you start removing documents and adding different ones at some point the vector database might be like the data structures might be kind of stale so i'll give you an example like an extreme example let's say you add a ton of vectors, but only the first dimension isn't zero. So the vector database is basically going to create a bunch of partitions around that first dimension and ignore the rest, right? If you take those documents out and insert a bunch of documents where only the second dimension isn't zero, but you still use the old partitioning scheme they're all going to fall in the same
向量数据库，它创建所有这些数据结构，然后你可以给它向量查询，它会告诉你最近的邻居。向量数据库负责管理那里的动态。所以，例如，如果你开始删除文档并添加不同的文档，在某个时候，向量数据库可能会……数据结构可能会有点过时。所以我给你举个例子，一个极端的例子。假设你添加了一堆向量，但只有第一个维度不是零。所以向量数据库基本上会在第一个维度周围创建一堆分区，而忽略其余部分，对吧？如果你把那些文档拿出来，插入一堆只有第二个维度不是零的文档，但你仍然使用旧的分区方案，它们都会落在同一个
bucket and now you don't have that speed up anymore and so the vector database is responsible for like knowing when to rebalance and re-index just like your hard drive has to occasionally rebalance the b-trees on the on the folders of your hard drive what's old is new again yeah exactly um so um yeah and then beyond that just all of the traditional database things you know backups and restores um all of all of that stuff that we've come to appreciate from databases uh you know vector databases have to provide that as well so if you have like you mentioned so you like euclidean distance or you hear like cosine similarity or whatever if you want to change the metric do you need or does per metric is there needed a different clustering
桶里，现在你没有那种速度提升了。所以向量数据库负责知道何时重新平衡和重新索引，就像你的硬盘有时必须重新平衡硬盘文件夹上的 B 树一样。旧的东西又变新了。是的，完全正确。所以，嗯，是的，除此之外，还有所有传统的数据库功能，你知道，备份和恢复，所有那些我们已经开始欣赏的数据库功能，你知道，向量数据库也必须提供这些。所以如果你有，就像你提到的，你喜欢欧几里得距离，或者你听说过余弦相似度之类的，如果你想改变度量，你需要，或者每个度量是否需要不同的聚类
or is it like one is good for all of them yeah it's a good question. You basically need a different... Well, the answer is always going to be it depends on the data, right? But definitely, you can construct datasets where each clustering, each similarity metric needs its own clustering and you can show that you know uh that there is a data set where you know any clustering can only be good in one of these three different similarity metrics so it's possible now in practice in practice i wouldn't be surprised if these database systems just use euclidean distance for the clustering and then you pay a slight penalty if you're using something else. I think for 99% of cases, that would be fine.
还是说一种度量适用于所有情况？是的，这是一个好问题。你基本上需要一个不同的……好吧，答案总是“这取决于数据”，对吧？但绝对地，你可以构建数据集，其中每个聚类、每个相似性度量都需要自己的聚类，你可以证明，你知道，存在一个数据集，其中任何聚类只能在三种不同相似性度量中的一种中表现良好。所以这是可能的。现在在实践中，在实践中，如果这些数据库系统只是使用欧几里得距离进行聚类，然后如果你使用其他度量，你会付出轻微的代价，我不会感到惊讶。我认为在 99% 的情况下，这都没问题。
Makes sense. Yeah, and so this is where, this is definitely in the category kind of like authentication. It's in the category of things you don't want to write yourself. Oh, come on. It's going to be pretty gnarly.
有道理。是的，所以这绝对属于像身份验证那样的类别。它属于你不想自己编写的那类东西。哦，得了吧。那会非常棘手。
You know, even some of the top vector databases are only now starting to become mature. So, for example, you know, I've used in the past Milvus, which is an open source vector database and um we had issues where when we tried to back up the database it would crash and we would lose everything um and so um you know definitely i would say it's still at the phase where you probably want to store your embeddings just in a regular database as well um it's still kind of early. But you know, every month, it gets massively more mature because so many people are using it. The one that I so Milvus is good. pinecone is a enterprise alternative pinecone is a lot better, but you're going to pay for it. You get what you pay for there. Another one that I really appreciate is PG vector,
你知道，即使是一些顶级的向量数据库也才刚刚开始变得成熟。所以，例如，你知道，我过去使用过 Milvus，这是一个开源向量数据库，我们遇到过一些问题，当我们尝试备份数据库时，它会崩溃，我们会丢失所有东西。所以，你知道，我绝对会说它仍然处于你可能也想将嵌入存储在常规数据库中的阶段，它仍然有点早期。但你知道，每个月，它都在变得更加成熟，因为有太多人在使用它。我所欣赏的一个……Milvus 是好的。Pinecone 是一个企业级替代方案，Pinecone 好得多，但你要为此付费。你在那里一分钱一分货。我非常欣赏的另一个是 PG Vector，
which is an extension to Postgres that lets you have vector columns in an existing table. And that's really nice, right? Because you could have, you know, like a row, have like, imagine you're storing houses um your zillow or something right so you could have a row and the row has like an id the address of the house uh the number of bedrooms like all of this explicit information and then in that same table you just add a column that's like you know embedding and that column is backed by pg vector
它是 Postgres 的一个扩展，允许你在现有表中拥有向量列。这真的很好，对吧？因为你可以有，你知道，比如一行，有……想象你在存储房子，你是 Zillow 之类的，对吧？所以你可以有一行，这一行有 ID、房子的地址、卧室数量，所有这些显式信息，然后在同一个表中，你只需添加一个列，比如“嵌入”，该列由 PG Vector 支持。
and it works pretty naturally so you could um this is actually another thing you know the approximate nearest neighbors it assumes that they're all valid right but like uh for example let's say you only want three bedroom houses that are approximate nearest neighbors right that's actually a really hard thing to do because you might pull like the nearest thousand neighbors but they're all two bedroom i have to pull another thousand another thousand another thousand until finally you have enough to fill up the three bedroom limit that you set so um there's a lot of complexity there um but uh but yeah you know these these database systems are really good at at handling all of that for you yeah i i would love to like find an excuse use this. It always sounds really interesting and cool. And I know I'm obsessed with tinkering.
它工作起来非常自然。所以你可以……这实际上是另一件事，你知道，近似最近邻，它假设它们都是有效的，对吧？但例如，假设你只想要三居室的房子，它们是近似最近邻，对吧？这实际上是一件非常难做的事情，因为你可能会拉出最近的一千个邻居，但它们全是两居室的。我必须再拉一千个，再拉一千个，再拉一千个，直到最后你有足够的数量来填满你设置的三居室限制。所以，这里有很多复杂性。但，是的，你知道，这些数据库系统非常擅长为你处理所有这些。是的，我很想找个借口使用这个。它听起来总是非常有趣和酷。而且我知道我沉迷于修补。
So I'd love to find a use, but just haven't had one yet. Yeah, I mean, for me, the one use case that I've found outside of work has been nearest neighbors on my photos. It's not too hard to use one of these open source models, embed all of your photos, and then given one of your family photos, you find all the nearest ones. Google Photos, these other things will do it for you.
所以我很想找到一个用途，但只是还没有找到。是的，我的意思是，对我来说，我在工作之外发现的一个用例是在我的照片上进行最近邻搜索。使用这些开源模型之一，嵌入你所有的照片，然后给定你的一张家庭照片，你找到所有最接近的照片，这并不太难。Google Photos，这些其他东西会为你做这件事。
So it's really more of a fun exercise for you to do than something that's providing a lot of unique utility. But that's been a fun thing that I've been able to do that's something that's you know providing a lot of unique utility but um that's been a fun thing that uh that i've been able to do with it cool all right um that is a ramp up on vector databases if you're doing anything with vector databases let us know give us a shout out go on the discord uh the discord is starting to pick up some steam a lot of really interesting discussions about career uh changing jobs should i be a consultant after i leave my company a lot of really interesting discussions there so check it out uh okay i will i will i will take that as a personal message
所以这更多的是一个有趣的练习，而不是提供很多独特实用性的东西。但这一直是我能够做的一件有趣的事情，这是一件……你知道，提供很多独特实用性的东西，但这一直是我能够用它做的一件有趣的事情。酷，好的，嗯，这就是关于向量数据库的入门。如果你正在用向量数据库做任何事情，请告诉我们，给我们点个赞，去 Discord 上看看。Discord 开始变得热闹起来，有很多关于职业、换工作的非常有趣的讨论，“我离开公司后应该做顾问吗？”那里有很多非常有趣的讨论，所以去看看吧。好的，我会，我会，我会把它当作一条私人信息。
well i got you covered, Patrick. I will be there, but it'll be a bot. That's right. Patrick's AI will be there and you can interact with it. This is awesome. I learned a lot. So thanks, Jason. And thanks, everyone, for listening.
好吧，我帮你搞定了，Patrick。我会去的，但那将是一个机器人。没错。Patrick 的 AI 会在那里，你可以与它互动。这太棒了。我学到了很多。所以谢谢 Jason。也谢谢大家的收听。
Cool. All right, everyone. Thanks so much for supporting us on Patreon. We really appreciate it. And we will catch you all later. Have a good one. and share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
酷。好的，各位。非常感谢大家在 Patreon 上支持我们。我们真的很感激。我们稍后再见。祝大家过得愉快。并以同样的方式分享。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。